Nice!
Und dann ist es fertig.
Und jetzt geht es weiter.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
So.
Leute, ich sag euch, ich hab's ganz schön in den Beinen.
Äh.
Boah.
Ich bin heute...
Warte mal, ich gucke mal kurz.
Ja.
Ich bin heute 11,42 Kilometer gerannt.
6,19er Pace.
was jetzt weder
sonderlich schnell noch super langsam ist
das ist so
das was quasi
mir die Garmin App empfiehlt
für längere
Ausdauersachen
145er Puls
im Durchschnitt und das ganze hat gedauert
1 Stunde 12
Das merke ich
Also ich habe, runden wir mal auf
Also ich habe knapp 12 Kilometer in den Beinen
Das merkt man
Keine Ahnung wie die Marathon Leute das machen
Die einfach doppelt so schnell rennen
Für 42 Kilometer
Aber gut das ist auch schon echt
Unmenschlich die Leute
Das ist krass
Und die rennen ja nicht immer mal doppelt so schnell, die rennen ja mehr als doppelt so schnell.
Wusstet ihr eigentlich, dass heute Weltkatzentag ist oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung?
Habe ich vorhin auf Twitter gelesen.
auf ex-formally-known-as-Twitter.
Und ich hab
meine neue Schuhe bestellt.
Guck mal.
Ich hab mir jetzt noch zusätzlich
Ich mach mal ein Ticken leiser.
Ja, also ich hab mir noch ein paar neue Laufschuhe bestellt.
Und zwar, ich hab ja aktuell so für...
So dämpfungsmäßig...
Benutz ich den hier.
So sieht's aus.
Das Teil hab ich schon eine ganze Weile.
Okay, Platinium heißt das nicht.
Keine Ahnung, warum das Platinium ist.
Einfach nur ohne...
Also ich hab das ohne Platinium.
Warum auch immer es da jetzt Platinium,
Platinium, ATC, was auch immer gibt.
Ich hab so einen ganz normalen, ja.
Also so einen...
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Also so ein Ding ungefähr.
Nicht in grün, ich hab das Ding hier so in...
Was ist denn meine Farbe? Das da?
Ja, sowas in der Richtung.
Und das ist halt richtig nice, weil man hier unten, ihr seht es ja schon, das ist halt super weich gedämpft.
Du hast halt, wenn du damit rennst, ist es ein bisschen wie wenn du so auf...
Stellt euch vor, ihr lauft auf Marshmallows.
mir los so ungefähr fühlt sich das erstmal an hat halt den riesen vorteil
wenn du längere zeit rennt damit geht das halt nicht so sehr auf füße
schienbeine waden knie und sonst was also das ist dem fall sehr gut
der nachteil ist du singst hat auch ganz schön rein und kannst dich wirklich
damit ergonomisch schnell laufen nee das ist genau für leute wie dich ist das gut weil leute
die schwer sind die da ist natürlich auch die die belastung so auf gelenken und sehen und schien
bei allem größer genau genau genau dafür ist das gemacht unter anderem ich habe auch von vielen
leuten auf reddit gelesen die am fließband arbeiten und den ganzen tag
stehen oder leute im krankenhaus auf der notaufnahme die den ganzen tag rum
rumlaufen die haben tatsächlich aus solche solche dämpfungsschuhe an das
problem ist halt wenn du damit schneller laufen willst du kannst damit
selbstverständlich schneller laufen das problem ist nur dass der schuh hat
nicht dafür gemacht dass du singst da rein es wird schön gedämpft aber das
halt keine Energieabgabe irgendwie
wieder nach oben, ja, nach vorne.
Also du musst dich da deutlich mehr
anstrengen, in den Schuhen schnell zu laufen, wie mit
anderen. Und jetzt habe ich mir einen neuen
gekauft, das habe ich mir einen
Superplast 3, die Dinger
haben ja auch, äh, Plast,
die Dinger haben ja auch Namen, ne?
So ein
Teil hier, habe ich mir jetzt gekauft.
Der kann angeblich,
der ist fast, fast,
also angeblich, ne, ich hab, ich hab
Reviews gelesen. Der ist fast
genauso gut gedämpft. Also,
es ist nicht ganz so komfortabel
wie der Gehlenimbus. Es ist nicht
ganz so viel gedämpft. Dafür
dämpft er schön
und gibt aber, ist sehr
leicht und gibt auch ordentlich Energie wieder
ab, wenn du ein bisschen schneller laufen willst.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt hier noch so ein zweites Paar Schuhe
geholt.
Mit LED, naja,
wenn schon RGB-LED.
Genau. Und
Irgendwie kriegt das DHL nicht hin, mir den Schuh zu liefern.
Ich gucke mal kurz in die DHL-App.
Nee, immer noch nicht.
Geil.
Ursprünglich hieß es am 7., also am Freitag, sollten die Schuhe kommen.
Aber seit Donnerstagabend steht die Sendung bei DHL, die Sendung würde elektronisch angekündigt.
Also keine Ahnung, die haben jetzt einfach zwei Tage nichts gemacht mit der Sendung.
Einfach liegen lassen.
Also ob ich den hier empfehlen kann, weiß ich noch nicht.
Den muss ich dann mal die nächsten Wochen ausprobieren.
Laut Essex ist das auch ein super Trainerschuh.
Das ist halt bla bla bla.
Im Prinzip wollen die damit sagen, er ist dafür gemacht,
dass du möglichst breites Spektrum an unterschiedlichen Trainingslängen und Intensität abdecken kannst.
Und ich würde dann wahrscheinlich in Zukunft mehr oder weniger halbe-halbe machen.
Also alles, was Grundlagenausdauermäßig und langsam Recovery und sowas ist,
ziehe ich weiterhin meinen Gil Nimbus an und für alles andere ziehe ich dann den hier an.
Bedeutet, dass der Versender das Paket noch nicht an DHL übergeben hat.
Okay, der Shop selber sagt aber, Versand ist erfolgt.
Vielleicht erzählen die auch Mist.
Kann auch sein, dass die Chebaden...
Möglich ist es ja.
dass der Shop
dass Essex mich geballert hat
ja, ja gut, das stimmt
so Leute, heute machen wir
eine ganz wilde Mischung
heute
machen wir ein bisschen
Containerkram, beziehungsweise ich hab
Ich hab, Leute, ich hab, äh, warum auch immer ich das hier offen hab, keine Ahnung.
Ich hab, Chat, das ist auch wieder so was.
Manchmal ist, hat mein Hirn so Aussetzer.
Ich switch dann rüber und denk mir, Max, warum genau hast du dieses Bild jetzt hier im Fullscreen auf und sonst nichts?
Keine Ahnung, warum ich das aufhab.
Heute müssen wir ein bisschen Containerkram basteln.
Weil ich entwickle ja seit einer ganzen Weile nur in Containern.
Und das liegt daran, also wirklich entwickeln, nicht laufen lassen die Software.
Und das liegt daran, weil es mich halbwegs vor Supply Chain Angriffen schützt.
Nur ein Tab im Browser.
Ja, Moment.
Wir haben ja das hier auch noch.
Also wir haben schon noch genug Tabs.
So ist das nicht.
Also wie gesagt, ich entwickle ja hauptsächlich in Containern und ich habe für Python-Entwicklung
keinen Container bisher.
Das wollen wir mal ausprobieren, wie wir das am besten machen.
Und dann müssen wir noch ein Docker-File bauen für Python-Compilation, so das was
für gestern gemacht haben, sodass man das
immer auf Knopfdruck starten kann.
Und dann, das ist wahrscheinlich,
oder was heißt und dann, das kommt, ist ja alles parallel.
Und dann bauen wir
eine Python-CLI-App
und ich lerne mal, wie das
geht. Wir bauen dann den, keine Ahnung,
den PyCagW
Champ oder so.
Den PyCagW Champ
und der kann dann, da machen
wir dann, ne, hier,
keine ahnung server oder so oder machen wir irgendwie eine hello world webseite rein die
included ist
Minus minus help oder also im prinzip gucken wir uns mal an wie man command line argumente passt und wie man ordentliche
CLA ausgabe macht als irgendwelche tabellen ausgeben und so was mal gucken halt dass wir das war eine ordentliche
CLA anwendung haben und das packen wir dann am ende als selfcontained binary ein
und freuen uns dass es so gut funktioniert
Wie entwickelst du im Container?
Ist das H in den Container oder wie?
Zeige ich dir.
Für Python habe ich noch nichts.
Wir machen das mal anders.
Wir nehmen jetzt mal...
Keine Ahnung.
Für was habe ich denn fertige Templates?
.net, Go, Quarkus, Rust.
Okay, Rust machen wir jetzt mal.
Also.
Also das hier hat jetzt mit...
Das hier hat jetzt mit...
Hallo?
Das hat jetzt mit Containern hier erstmal nichts zu tun.
Cookiecutter ist ein mega nices Projekt.
Benutze ich jetzt seit ungefähr einem Jahr.
Damit kann man für neue Projekte...
Also damit kann man neue...
Projekte erzeugen aus Template-Projekten.
Was halt sehr nice ist.
Man kann sich quasi einmal alles so einrichten, wie man es gerne für .NET hätte, wie man es für Go hätte, wie man es für Java hätte, wie man es für Rust hätte.
Und dann sagt man, okay, nimm dieses Basisprojekt und erzeugt mir daraus jetzt ein neues Rust-Projekt.
Projektname, Rust, YouTube Chat.
So, und dann haben wir dann hier, hat es das angelegt.
So, und jetzt zeige ich dir, wie das funktioniert, wie ich ihn kontinuier.
Also ich zeige dir erstmal ohne die Details.
Ich habe einen Alias
Um dieses ganze Bild zu starten
Zack
Was für eine IDE wollen wir verwenden
Wir sind Rust, wir verwenden
Rust Rover
So und ich gucke jetzt erstmal ob der ganze Mist
Überhaupt noch funktioniert
Wenn er noch funktioniert, dann zeige ich dir wie es unter der Haube funktioniert
Genau
Der baut jetzt erstmal einen Container
Da ist ein Dockerfile drin
Der baut jetzt erstmal einen Container, installiert so ein paar Basic Sachen drauf
installiert rast das aktuelle rast rein und
compile tages und so alles was man braucht also der baut jetzt erst mal den container
und das dauert also beim ersten start dauert das ein bisschen wenn man so neues projekt angelegt
hat macht mir jetzt eine halbe stunde vielleicht ist auch kaputt der macht noch dinger ok von
snoch okay ja da müssen wir jetzt kurz beim container bauen zu gucken das musst du nur
einmal pro projekt machen dann ist das gecached also initial wenn so ein projekt startest
was ist der vorteil dass du in der sandbox bisher ich weiß nicht hat er hat auch mitgekriegt wie
oft das supply chain angriff in letzter zeit gibt er heute keinen tag das haltet aus und
wenn du das alles in einem container machst und in den container jetzt nicht unbedingt
sachen rein gemontet hast wie dein komplettes home verzeichnis oder so da bist du erst mal
deutlich sicherer unterwegs weil selbst wenn du dir über irgendeinen supply chain angriff
was einfängst ist erst mal im container drin ja nicht nur das arch user repo
npm sogar pip.net hatte auch was java hatte auch was supply chain angriffe überall so
So, jetzt muss ich mich connecten in den Container und dann geht meine IDE auf.
Und dann zeige ich dir, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Wie gesagt, der erste Start dauert ein bisschen.
Du musst den Container bauen, dann muss die IDE-Connection sich runterladen und alles.
Aber du entwickelst auf der IDE
Auf deinem Rechner, jaja
Ich zeige euch gleich, wie das funktioniert
Moin Abriss Johnny
Ich muss jetzt nur noch mal testen, dass es noch funktioniert
Weil ich habe das noch nicht auf dem neuen Mini-PC bisher verwendet
Jaja, wir trusten
Wir trusten dem Projekt
So, und jetzt haben wir hier Rust Rover
Und hoffentlich funktioniert alles
Ich schieb das mal auf Desktop 3.
Weil normalerweise hab ich das so.
Was?
Man braucht eine Lizenz für...
Ah ne hier. Start Trial.
Okay. Start 30 Days Trial.
Excellent.
Nochmal.
Nochmal Glück gehabt.
Ghosty. Ghosty hab ich ignored bisher.
30 Tage Trial. Jaja.
Boah das laggt immer.
Alter, das Chat, guck mal hier, das Chatplans-Zeug beim Startup ist so krasser Shit.
Guckt euch das an, Mann.
Oh, erst mal diesen ganzen Mist hier zumachen.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, man muss jetzt noch das hier laden.
Wartet mal, ich bin ganz...
Das ist nicht so genau.
Wartet mal.
Hat das jetzt schon eine Weile...
Ach, Workspaces.
Muss ich Workspaces...
Ich glaube, das braucht man jetzt.
Das Window.
Ja, JetBrains IDE ist die beste.
Die sind halt gerade am Anfang, wenn du so neu startest,
ist das echt lahm und hakelig
ein bisschen rum.
Genau. So, guck mal. Jetzt haben wir hier
unser Rust-Projekt.
So, also.
Wir haben jetzt hier unsere IDE
mit dem ganzen Rust-Gedöns drin.
Wie macht man den Rust-Rover denn?
Die Schriftart ein bisschen
größer.
Das ist nicht Mausrad.
Font Size.
Change Font Size with Wheel.
Excellent.
So, also.
Gut, jetzt haben wir alles gestartet.
Jetzt kann ich das Ganze kurz zeigen.
Also nachdem ich hier meinen Container zu entwickeln gestartet habe,
habe ich jetzt hier eine Idee, kann Gedöns machen
und hier bin ich per SSH auf den Container verbunden.
Und jetzt habe ich hier so ein paar Dinger,
wie gesagt, das ist ein Rust-Projekt,
da habe ich mir irgendwann mal ein Template dafür angelegt.
Ich kann jetzt hier sagen run und so
und dann kompiliert er meinen Rust-Gedöns.
Also das hat mit dem Container nichts zu tun,
das ist, ich habe mir so ein Template-Projekt
für Sachen, die ich hauptsächlich verwende, angelegt
und dass ich das nicht jedes Mal machen muss.
So, und wie das Ganze funktioniert ist,
also erst mal vom Setup her mega nice.
IDE läuft bei mir hier auf dem KDE-Desktop,
connectet sich per JetBrains Gateway,
per SSH in den Container.
Achso, nee, run will ich nicht, ich will build.
Connectet sich in den Container rein per SSH
und hier habe ich den Terminal auf, auch per SSH
connected in den Container. Was halt
sehr nice ist, weil du kannst
das verwenden, wie wenn es
lokal bei dir auf der
VM liegt, nur dass es halt noch mal
in einem Container gesendboxed ist
und dich das,
sagen wir mal, 95% immun
gegen Supply Chain Angriffe macht.
Solange du da nicht irgendwie Gott um die Welt
reingemountet hast in den Container, ja?
Das bringt dir natürlich auch nichts.
und wie das Ganze funktioniert ist folgendermaßen
also jetzt sieht man schon mal vom Ansatz her
genau, also was
im Container ist, der Container wird in dem Fall
gebaut für Rust, das heißt
der installiert Rust, der installiert
Cargo, der installiert
als Basis benutze ich Debian Trixi
als
dann installiert er noch so ein paar Basic Sachen, die man
braucht, kann ich gleich alles noch zeigen
paar Basic Sachen, die man
braucht, er klont, davor habe ich
mir halt dieses projekt geklont hier aus meinem projekt template und dann startet
den container verbindet sich per ssh drauf und die connection läuft auch per
ssh also spricht die idee läuft auf dem desktop der code selber liegt oder
connectet sich in den container rein und benutzt die programme die in dem container
drin sind das funktioniert aber nur mit ideen und editoren die so einen agent
dafür haben. Bei JetBrains
gibt es hier
JetBrains Gateway.
Der verbindet sich
dann per SSH auf eine
Linux-Kiste, kann ein Container sein, kann er vor allem in der
Cloud sein, ist egal. Dort wird ein kleiner
Mini-Client runtergeladen.
Das heißt, die IDE GUI,
die läuft hier auf dem Desktop.
Das heißt, die ist schön snappy und schnell.
So Sachen wie
Source-Code-Analyse
und sowas,
das läuft
auf dem Container. Da gibt es so einen
JetBrains Agent, der dann da drauf läuft.
Gibt es auch VVS Code? Ja.
Ja, gibt es auch VVS Code.
Ich kann es dir gleich
zeigen, wie das funktioniert. Also,
es ist halt richtig nice, weil
du hast quasi
vorgefertigtes Projekt mit allem, was du brauchst
drinne und du bist, und das ist
halt auch der hauptsächliche Grund, warum
ich das so
eingerichtet habe vor einem Jahr,
dass man halt nicht
so sehr betroffen ist, wenn man mal einen
Supply Chain Angriff erwischt.
Weil die Frage ist ja nicht,
bist du von einem
Supply Chain Angriff mal betroffen?
Sondern die Frage ist eher,
wann?
Jeder wird früher oder später mal
von einem Supply Chain
Angriff betroffen sein.
Chatge, ist allen klar,
was ein Supply Chain Angriff ist?
Das war jetzt zwar
in den News
die letzten Monate
und Wochen immer mal wieder.
Aber ich kann es trotzdem mal kurz erklären.
Also, wenn du was programmierst,
es ist erstmal egal, in welcher Programmiersprache.
Ja, also Python.net, Java,
C-Sharp,
Rust,
OliTime, genau.
Also es ist erstmal wurscht, ja.
So, und egal in welcher
Programmiersprache du was programmierst,
du wirst ja nie alles selber
programmieren also wirst immer irgendwelche sachen benutzen wollen die andere leute für
dich was heißt für dich das stimmt ja nicht die andere leute schon im vorfeld mal entwickelt haben
zum beispiel nehmen wir mal rast wenn wir einen web server starten willst rast hat kein web server
eingebaut du musst du web server library verwenden also nach installieren preisen hat glaube ich weiß
ich nicht haben die webseite eingebaut die meisten leute ins den flaschen oder so was
wird musste nach installieren bei not jes musste für 330 gigabyte erst mal noten und nach installieren
also muss libraries auf die von denen du abhängst musst du nach installieren so und jetzt war es die
letzten monate über so zum beispiel wenn wir mpn npm nehmen npm nehmen das ist eine registry also
quasi in den repo sammlung könnte man sagen das ist eine sammlung aus javascript libraries die
kann man bei jedem javascript projekt dazu installieren und benutzen willst du farbige
konsolen ausgabe machen installiert einen installierten npm package was farbige konsolen
ausgabe einfach möglich macht ja so das problem ist jetzt nur er stimmt du hast recht genau ja
Jaja, Meistertypkit. Das ist ja dieser One-Liner, den viele verwenden, um Directory zu surfen.
So, das Problem ist jetzt nur, diese Libraries hier, die werden von Leuten erstellt und zur Verfügung gestellt auf NPM.
Wenn jetzt diese Leute gehackermanned werden oder jemand denen ihre SSH-Keys oder ihre Credentials für NPM klaut,
Nehmen wir mal das wichtigste JavaScript-Package aller Zeiten und zwar isod. Das ist immer ein gutes Beispiel. Also ja, es gibt eine JavaScript-Library, um zu checken, ob ein int gerade ist oder nicht.
Es gibt zwar ganz viele Konstrukte in der Sprache, um das ohne eine Zusatzlibrary zu machen, aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen gibt es eine JavaScript Library, um zu checken, ob eine Zahl gerade oder ungerade ist.
übrigens hier, by the way, hier, seht ihr das?
Weekly, weekly
Downloads, seht ihr das hier unten?
1,1
Millionen
Weekly Downloads
Ja, der
Source Code für diese Library ist halt
dieses legit, äh, 5
Zeilen oder so
Es ist, es ist nicht
Modulo 2, das kommt, das
kommt erst ganz am Ende, vorher
checkt er noch 30 Sachen, ob er
irgendwie int ist und danach macht er
Modulo 2.
Also gibt es.
So, und jetzt stellt euch mal vor,
der Autor
dieses npm-Pakets,
also dieser JavaScript Library,
dem wird
seine
npm-Zugangsdaten geklaut.
Und jetzt
veröffentlicht einer eine neue Version,
jetzt veröffentlicht einer,
mit dem seinen Credentials
ist Ort 302.
Und dort hat er,
nehmen wir mal was Naheliegendes,
einen Krypto-Miner drin.
Ja, oder noch viel besser,
einen SSH-Key-Stealer und sowas.
Kannst du ja machen, ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Und jetzt pusht er das als 302
und alle, die sagen,
ja, ich will eine Version, die mit 3 anfängt,
beim nächsten NPM-Update haben die das.
und schon hast du dir irgendeinen Mist eingefangen.
NPM ist das größte Negativbeispiel dafür,
weil NPM, glaube ich, die letzten,
Ahnung, 10 Jahre oder so,
laufen, es vergeht eigentlich keine Woche,
ohne einen größeren Supply Chain Angriff auf NPM.
Es liegt aber auch daran,
weil NPM so ein paar Sachen früher gemacht hat,
die nicht so geil waren.
Du hattest beispielsweise Post-Install-Hooks in solchen Packages, die dann irgendwie auf deinem Rechner Sachen machen konnten.
So was ganz abgedrehtes Zeug.
Ist auch nicht mal so einfach, geht aber immer noch ohne Probleme da das zu Zweck empfremden.
Und das nennt man Supply Chain Angriff.
Also sprich, wenn der Account hier von dem Anbieter gehijackt wird und eine infizierte Version hochgeladen wird.
Das gibt es für so gut wie alle
Programmiersprachen, denen kann das passieren
Bei JavaScript
haben wir NPM
Bei Rust haben wir
Crates
Wofür hat das eigentlich
eine Dependency? Das ist eine gute Frage
Ist Number
Die das da muss jetzt gleich mal den source code zu angucken zu essen am bar
Yes excellent
Aber es muss man nicht hinterfragen das ist javascript leute
So bei russ hammer crates
bei dot net haben
Bei
Bei Java weiß ich es gerade aus dem Kopf nicht, wie da das Repo gedöhnt heißt.
Bei Python haben wir hier PyPy oder wie das heißt.
Äh, keine Ahnung. Chat, ich weiß gar nicht.
Wie heißt die Python Container Registry?
Nee, Maven ist das Build Tool. Ich suche das NPM Gegenstück für Java.
Python Package.
Package Index.
Ja, genau das Ding.
Ah, seht ihr, das gibt es für jede
Programmiersprache, außer, jetzt kommt
der Witz, C++.
C++ hat sowas nicht.
C++ hat halt einfach gar kein
Dependency, Library,
Abhängigkeitsmanagement.
Es gibt ein paar Third-Party-Dinger für
C++. VC-Package ist nicht
das einzige, aber das kannst
du halt nicht vergleichen mit sowas wie
NPM oder Cargo.
Erstens sind die Dinger nicht sonderlich verbreitet,
der C auch nicht.
sind die dinge nicht sonderlich verbreitet und die registry ist nicht so sonderlich komplett
und außerdem ist das format mit ihrem ganzen header file geschiss auch echt unpraktisch
zu packen also ihr seht es gibt es gibt für nahezu jede moderne programmiersprache bei ruby
sind es gems ruby gems beispielsweise noch hier also jede halbwegs moderne programmiersprache
außer c++ hat so eine zentrale library package registry wurde dir sachen installieren kannst
und dann aus seinem programm verwenden kannst so und wenn da jetzt irgendwie ein paket übernimmt
stellt euch mal vor jemand wird ruby und rails übernehmen und eine ruby und rails version
pushen die irgendwelche kilo grad drin hat dass wir hätten auch auf einen schlag 10.000 zehntausende
Leute. So, und
jetzt ist die Frage halt nicht,
fange ich mir irgendwann mal
ein manipuliertes Paket
ein, sondern die Frage ist
eher wann. Das wird früher oder später
passieren, da kommt man eigentlich nicht dran vorbei.
Das heißt, man muss sich überlegen,
wie kann man das
am besten
eindämmen, dass
wenn es einen erwischt, weil wie gesagt, die Frage ist
nicht wenn, ist nicht ob, sondern
wann, wie kann man das am besten
eindämmen, wenn es dann mal
passiert. Ich bin da für mich zu dem
Schluss gekommen,
ich entwickle einfach nur noch in
Containern.
Und in diese Container habe ich auch nichts
Großartiges reingemountet.
Also ich habe gar nichts von meinem Host
reingemountet, weil es würde ja keinen Sinn
machen, wenn ich mein Heimatverzeichnis
in den Container maunte
und dort irgendwie
über irgendein manipuliertes Paket
SSH-Credentialstealer reinkommt
und sowas.
Das hat ja keinen Sinn. Also deswegen, ich
entwickle in Containern,
wo möglichst wenig drin gemountet ist.
Halt im Prinzip nur
der Source-Code, den ich brauche, ist gemountet.
Und
die Container haben halt das, was ich brauche,
um in der jeweiligen Sprache entwickeln zu können.
Und mittlerweile kann Wischel Studio
Code und JetBrains können das richtig gut
remote auf Containern, beziehungsweise
auf VMs entwickeln.
Chatgear, ich hab ein Problem.
Ich hab gerade, das ist mir irgendwie nicht so gut bekommen.
Ich hab
Pilze mit Rahmsauce
und vegetarischem Hackfleisch
gefuttert. Nicht vegetarischem,
veganem Hackfleisch gefuttert.
Das habe ich schon öfters gegessen.
Hatte ich nie Probleme mit.
Aber ich muss mal kurz...
Es drückt. Aber hier nix
anstellen.
Ich habe euch im Glück, Leute. Und danach
gehe ich auf die Sachen im Chat ein und ich zeige euch das.
Ich zeige euch auch das, wie ich das mache mit dem
Container. Nix anstellen hier.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Ich hab doch noch so ein Aff-Klo
Warte mal, Aff-Klo?
Perfekt
So, gleich wieder da
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Da bin ich wieder.
Ich muss ja sagen, ich bin seit jetzt, weiß ich nicht, drei Monaten oder so.
Irgendwie, halben Jahr vielleicht.
Na, eher drei Monate.
Bin ich ja jetzt Teilzeit-Veganer.
Und mir bekommt es echt gut.
Ich bin viel leistungsfähiger und fitter, wenn ich nicht Massenfleisch futter.
Vielleicht ist es auch Einbildung.
Aber für gesundheitsmäßig und Wohlbefinden ist das nicht verkehrt.
Aber 100% Veganer werde ich wahrscheinlich nie werden.
Das heißt, die militante Veganerin wäre nicht zufrieden.
Hab keine Ahnung von Docker
Ist das nicht flüchtig
Wie ist das passiert, wenn du da drinnen was entwickelst
Ich zeig das jetzt
Hab ich ja gesagt, ich zeig euch jetzt wie das funktioniert
Aber prinzipiell
Docker ist an sich
Natürlich erstmal flüchtig
Wenn du den Container
gelöscht, ist weg.
Aber du kannst natürlich Verzeichnisse
reinmounten in den Docker-Container.
Die Persistenzen.
Und das passiert hier auch.
Der Source-Code wird da reingemountet.
So, also.
Wie funktioniert das Ganze? Machen wir das mal aus.
Aus, aus. Also sprich, hier ist
mein Container mit allem möglichen drauf.
Hier Rust, wie war das?
Cargo, Build, Blub.
Achso, ich muss vielleicht da reingehen.
hier. Cargo, Build,
sonst wie, seht ihr, das ganze Rascal-Lön ist da.
Und hier habe ich meine IDE, hier kann ich,
habe ich, ähm, Trace,
Alter.
Jetzt ist gerade heftig,
krasses Lagging angesagt.
Ach so, weil er gerade Cargo-Build macht, okay.
Cargo-Build, Cargo-Build,
äh, lastet gerade meine
Achtkernkiste aus.
So, gleich, gleich
haben wir es.
Okay, whatever
Also hier, so, hier, guck, hier hab ich Auto-Complete
Und alles mögliche
Tracing
Links hier, Doppelpunkt
Trace, also hier hab ich Auto-Complete
Und alles, was man so braucht
Also IDE ist voll funktionsfähig
IDE connect sich per SSH in den Container
Und hat da einen Agent, der da drin läuft
So, wie funktioniert das Ganze?
Ich zeige euch jetzt noch was cooles davon
Wenn ich jetzt fertig entwickeln bin, kann ich einfach sagen, DevPod, Delete und der Entwicklungscontainer ist rückstandslos.
Ihr seht ja auch No Connection, also sprich die IDE funktioniert nicht mehr.
Der Container ist rückstandslos wieder weg und alles was da drin installiert wurde und sonst wie in der Speicherplatte wieder freigegeben.
Das heißt, man versaut sich seine Kiste nicht so sehr.
Normalerweise, wenn du mehrere Sprachen...
Ich meine, ich mache regelmäßig Sachen in .NET.
Wir haben Java gemacht.
Wir haben C++, ESP32 Sachen gemacht.
Wir haben Python-Zeug gemacht, Ruby-Zeug, Bash.
Alles Mögliche haben wir gemacht, ja.
Und du brauchst ja für alles zusätzliche Tools.
Und da versaust du dir halt deine Entwicklungskiste ganz schön.
Vermisst du keine CLI-Tools im Container?
Nö, ich hab da eigentlich mehr oder weniger alles installiert, was ich will.
So, ich zeige euch jetzt auch, wie das funktioniert mit dem Container.
Löscht das das Docker-Image auch?
Keine Ahnung.
Ne.
Da muss man, wobei das gar nicht so schlecht ist, weil sonst braucht es beim nächsten Mal starten wieder ewig.
Genau, du musst ab und zu mal, musst du hier, hab ich ja noch gar nicht gemacht,
Docker, muss man hier Docker prune machen,
dass da ganze Mist wieder wegfliegt.
Das schadet eh nichts,
wenn man das so irgendwie einmal im Monat macht.
So, wie funktioniert
das Ganze? Also,
ich hab so ein Programm, was mir
aus einem
Template ein neues Projekt erzeugt.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an, sondern einfach
nur, was hier drin ist. Das ist jetzt exemplarisch ein
Rust-Projekt. Andere Sachen sehen so ähnlich
aus.
Ne, musst du nicht
jedes Mal bilden.
so
also was haben wir hier drin
wir haben einmal ein docker file
das ist ganz interessant
äh
das ist Blödsinn
das hat mit dem Container
überhaupt nichts zu tun
das ist für die App
könnt ihr ignorieren
ah hier haben wir es
also hier unter App ist ganz normal
die Rust App drin
der Rust Source Code
nichts besonderes dran
Uns geht es ja hier um die Container. Also was ich verwende, ich benenne eine Software für diese Entwicklungscontainer, die nennt sich DevPod. Achtung, DevPod ist ein Projekt, ist dieses Projekt hier, aber nicht diesen DevPod nehmen, weil dieses Projekt ist abandoned.
Da passiert seit zwei Jahren oder so nichts mehr richtig.
Ja, guck.
Also das ist total wenig.
Also das ist im Prinzip abandoned, das Projekt.
Aber DevPod wurde geforkt.
Von?
Ja, von dem hier.
Von Scavitor.
Er hat das geforkt.
Und er hat...
DevPod.
Das ist das Projekt, was ich für Entwicklungscontainer benutze.
Letztendlich ist DevPod, das ist eine Kommandozeilenanwendung.
Es gibt auch ein GUI.
Ganz ehrlich, ich verwende das GUI aber nicht.
Guck, das hat theoretisch auch ein GUI, aber wen juckt's?
Letztendlich braucht man nicht.
Und damit kannst du dann den Container bilden und machen und tun.
Ich habe mir das alles in ein Script gerappt.
Ich verwende DevPods direkt eigentlich gar nicht mehr.
Ich kann euch aber zeigen, was man für Dateien braucht, dass das Ganze funktioniert.
Es gibt einmal ein Docker-File.
Dieses Docker-File gibt es für jeden Projekttyp bei mir.
Das ist, was in den Dev-Container alles reinkommt.
Machen wir hier ein Wim auf.
Ja, also dieser ganze Schmodder kommt in den Dev-Container rein.
In dem Fall jetzt für Rust.
Ja, ich habe ein Base-Docker-File und dann für das jeweilige Projekt, aber das ist letztendlich egal.
Was mache ich?
Debian Trixi Image
erstmal alles updaten
so ein paar Standard Tools installieren
sudo, temux, htop, destat, curl
bash, ah, gedöns
ja, wird hier
installiert
dann noch ein bisschen
anderes, build essentials, Zeug, dass du
Sachen kompilieren kannst, das wird bei mir in jedem Container
gemacht, dann lege ich mir einen User
an
weil manche Sachen funktionieren
nicht richtig unter root
So, dann setze ich hier noch irgendwie ein paar Variablen, Terminal Color, UTF-8 Encoding, vollkommen egal.
Dann setze ich noch ein Wimmer C, Wimmer C, ich source alle Defaults und setze die Maus auf 0.
Das heißt, mein Wim macht kein komisches Selection, wenn ich da mit der Maus reinklicke, sondern hier Terminal Selection.
Dann setze ich noch ein paar andere TMAX Options für Color Output. Dann installiere ich mir den Nix Package Manager, OpenCode und meine OpenCode Config.
nee, OpenCode-Config
OpenCode benutze ich kaum noch in letzter Zeit
habe ich aber eine Weile verwendet, deswegen ist das
das ist so ein
Kommandozeilen-KI-Agent-Ding
so, ich installiere
mir auf allen Containern standardmäßig
Nix Package Manager, weil du kannst
halt so einfach wie
darüber bei Nix Software
nachinstallieren, wenn du was brauchst
einfach Nix Package, bam
ist am Start, so
das passiert bei jedem Container
so und das ist jetzt das Rust
Das ist ja hier End of Base Docker File. Das ist jetzt das Rust-spezifische für den Rust-Container.
Der installiert RustUp. RustUp ist ja quasi das Tool schlechthin, um Rust zu installieren.
Dann startet er eine neue Shell und in dieser Shell führt er aus RustUp Toolchain Install Nightly.
Das heißt, das installiert das tagesaktuelle Rust.
dann
addet er Linux Musel
als Compile Target
für Standalone Binaries und dann
addet er noch so ein paar Sachen Rust Source, Rust Standard
Rust FMT, Clippy, Rust
Docs
das ist das Dockerfile für den Entwicklungscontainer
ist relativ
übersichtlich, ja, wie gesagt ich hab so
ein BaseDockerfile, das hier oben passiert bei
allem und das da unten ist dann projektspezifisch
so, und das nächste
was ich mir dann gebaut
habe ist weil ich kenne mich ja ich kann theoretisch der ort ab ja also man kann
man kann der sport auch als kommandozeilen anwendungen so verwenden
das ding ist nur ich kann mir das nicht merken deswegen habe ich mir ein skript
gebaut das ist auch in jedem von meinen def
container drin also hier gibt es noch ein internet das macht bei der way gar
nichts könnte ich aber je nachdem falls ich mal was brauche was bei jedem
container statt ausgeführt wird hier noch reinschreiben
ich habe mir also da gucken was man die dev container jason an das ist ein
standard den sich microsoft ausgedacht hat da passiert auch nicht wirklich viel
da steht im prinzip nur drin wenn du den container erstellst benutzt das bild aus
dem docker file und dann maunze mir meine open code config rein für ki
gedöns was macht der fort ab anders als docker ab docker ab gibt es nicht docker
ab ist was du meinst ist docker compose ab das sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche
paar schuhe der sport ab macht im prinzip das was hier steht start new workspace im prinzip
nach der sport ab das was in der der container jason drin steht der point ab baut ihr das docker
file führt das post create command aus und macht mauns startete den container aber nachdem ich mir
diesen ganzen Krempel nicht merken kann und
noch ein paar besondere Sachen machen will und nicht merken
will, habe ich mir ein Skript gebaut.
Con.sh. Das
macht folgendes.
Browser Firefox Developer
Edition. Ich habe keine Ahnung,
ehrlich gesagt. Warum?
Wirklich, legit kein Plastenschimmer.
Warum ich da drin einen Browser gesetzt habe
und warum es ausgerechnet Firefox Developer Edition
ist. Kein Schimmer.
I don't know. Kein Plan.
So. Zumindest habe ich
hier ein Skript. Das
gibt ein Menü aus, wo ich die IDE
auswählen kann, mit welcher ich mich auf den
Container connecten will.
In dem Fall C-Line, Goland, Rider,
IntelliJ, Rust Rover, VS Code.
Da müssen wir für heute noch PyCharm reinschreiben.
Sudo ist nicht
standardmäßig Trainer in Debian Trixi.
Ne, ne, in Debian schon mal gar nicht.
So, und dann macht er im Prinzip genau das.
Er führt das aus, DevPod ab, Open IDE True und dann IDE halt hier C-Line, Golang, sonst wie was ich ausgewählt habe.
Das hier ist in der Schleife, weil manchmal möchte man sich ja auch mit mehreren Editoren und IDEs in einen Container verbinden.
Ja, zum Beispiel Rider für das C-Sharp Backend und VS Code für JavaScript Frontend.
mache ich aber äußerst selten, ist aber drin
und dann verbindet er sich
per SSH
auf den Pott
und das ist alles, wir schlängeln heute
das ist das Ziel, ja
und dann verbindet er sich hier per SSH
auf den Pott, nachdem er den hier oben gestartet hat
fertig, also man könnte
das auch alles von Hand machen
ja
und im Endeffekt
würde ich jetzt einfach
Achso, das hier
ist auch noch ein ganz tolles Skript, was nichts anderes macht
wie devcontainer.con.sh
ausführen
Also ich führe quasi
devcontainer.con.sh
aus, dann kriege ich
mein
Was
DevPod anders macht als die
VS Code Native Dev Container
Du brauchst nicht VS Code
Du kannst das mit
alle möglichen machen
Du brauchst nicht VS Code
und ich mag halt so ein CLI-Tool lieber als
irgendeine Visual Studio Code Plugin.
Jetzt kriegst du hier die Auswahl, die ich euch gezeigt
habe. Machen wir hier, ah ja, Rust Rover wollen wir
haben. Und jetzt passiert
im Endeffekt das, was ihr gesehen habt. Der macht
DevPod ab, hier drinnen
und dann macht er ein SSH auf den Pod.
Also er startet jetzt
die IDE und dann macht er ein SSH auf den
Pod und dann hast du deinen DevContainer
am Start.
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich diesen kram irgendwo mal auf github hochgeladen habe
guck jetzt haben wir den kram wieder aber das benutze ich seit ungefähr einem jahr so das setup
und für mich ist das optimale setup ich habe es möglichst isoliert falls ich mir mal supply chain
attack mäßig manipulierte packages einfangen und ich kann es mehr oder weniger so benutzen wie
lokal guck da verbindet sich automatisch macht die idee auf und jetzt kann es losgehen und
auf die frage hin ob denn die daten verloren gehen wenn man den container löscht das idee
becken installieren macht der pot automatisch ja das unterstützt ich weiß nicht was das alles
unterstützt ehrlich gesagt also wie es kaut auf jeden fall alle jet planes idee ist unterstützt
das und was sonst noch weiß ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht können wir mal nachgucken so und jetzt
habe ich guckt habe ich hier meine idee sagt ross gedöns und hier per ssh main container aber jetzt
immer kurz auf die frage hin nein nein nein nein nein ich will das server nicht hätten auf die
frage ob die daten vorhanden bleiben guck mal selbst wenn ich habe mir eben schon gesehen
Selbst wenn ich den Container wieder komplett lösche, alles wegschmeiße, der mountet letztendlich ja nur dieses Projektverzeichnis unter Slash Workspace in den Container rein.
Das heißt, es bleibt alles da.
Was du sonst allerdings in dem Container machst, also wenn du den Container jetzt startest und installierst da jetzt noch Node.js und Svelte CLI und so nach, das ist weg, wenn du den Container löscht und wieder startest.
Wenn du möchtest, dass das persistent ist, dann musst du das hier ins Docker-File reinschreiben.
Finde ich aber auch gut, weil das hat den Vorteil, letztendlich kannst du so ein Projekt pushen, auf einem anderen Rechner klonst du dir das Projekt, tust DevPod ab aus und du hast halt exakt den gleichen Zustand wieder.
Das heißt, es ist reproduzierbar. Finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Und wenn du Sachen da drin halt regelmäßig brauchst, muss man sie sich halt vorher ins Docker-File hauen.
Wo macht es Sinn, den generierten Source-Code zu speichern?
Meinst du? Auf GitHub? Auf GitHub? Auf GitLab? Bitbucket? Codeberg?
Kannst du dir überlegen, wo du willst. Auf jedem x-beliebigen Git-Repo kannst du dir, oder Git-Management-Service kannst du dir das speichern.
Das ist ja letztendlich auch ganz normal Text.
ich habe noch eine gitignore-file
das ist je nach Projekt ein bisschen anders
ja, also ich exklude hier mein
IDE-Config-Verzeichnis und
dort wo Rust die Binaries speichert
aber das hier ist ein ganz normales
Rust-Projekt letztendlich
guck, hast du gar
standardmäßigen Readme drin
kannst du hier nur ins Reinschreiben, ganz normales Rust-Projekt
und du musst auch nicht hier
diese Run- und Build-Skripte verwenden, kannst du das alles
selbst machen, hab ich nur für mich
mal angelegt
und dann hast du ein funktionierendes Projekt.
Persönlich, ich kann euch nur empfehlen,
guckt euch mal DevPod an.
Wie gesagt, diesen Fork hier vom Scevetta,
nicht das originale DevPod,
für mich ist das bis jetzt, was ich gefunden habe,
die optimale Art und Weise lokal zu entwickeln
und nicht so verwundbar zu sein
versus Supply Chain Angriffe.
Okay, extern.
Du musst es nicht extern speichern.
Ich habe beispielsweise intern ein GTA laufen,
wo ich den Kram drauf speichere.
Viele Sachen pushe ich auch erst gar nicht,
sondern lasse ich hier lokal auf meinem
Linux-Mini-PC liegen.
Ja, DevPod ist,
wie gesagt, DevPod ist
einmal, du hast, also wenn
du ein Projekt, wenn du jetzt dieses
Projekt hier pushen würdest,
mit diesem ganzen Dev-Container-Gedöns drin,
und dem Docker-File, dann könnte ich
mir das klonen, starten,
und ich hätte quasi genau
dein Setup. Um
Projekte zu teilen, wenn du mit mehreren Leuten
dran entwickeln willst, ist diese
Dev-Bot-Geschichte sicherlich was richtig geiles.
Verwende ich halt nicht. Die meisten Sachen
entwickle ich alleine von diesen
Sachen.
Und...
Der Pod
Ist halt immer konsistent dadurch, dass der nur das macht
Was in deinem Dockerfile...
Dass der nur das macht, was in deinem Dockerfile drin steht. Das heißt, wenn du DevPod abmachst, hast du einen
Entwicklungscontainer, der genau das hier enthält und sonst nix.
Ich hoffe, Frage beantwortet. Max, du hast auf Twitter gut Shit-Top...
Alter, die Leute, ey.
Der Twitter ist echt, ey.
Ganz besondere Ansammlung von Leuten.
Am schlimmsten auf Twitter,
ich habe ja gar nichts dagegen,
dass irgendwie jemand das anders sieht oder so.
Das ist eigentlich nicht das, was mich nervt.
Was mich nervt, sind Leute,
die sich selbst immer auf so ein
Podest stellen, so, aber ich
muss jetzt der Welt kundtun, ich
sehe das anders, denn ich bin moralisch
überlegen, das muss sich jetzt der Welt
erzählen und sich dann
auch ein bisschen zujubeln lassen von ihren
von ihren Follower-Leuten
und die Leute gehen mir immer richtig
auf den Sack, aber das hat
ein paar Leute echt getriggert, ich muss
dazu sagen, ja,
mir war das zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich das
gepostet hab auf Twitter, überhaupt
nicht klar, dass das
Busse sind, die explizit
hingestellt wurden,
um Obdachlose
zu schützen vor Hitzeschlag
und sonst was. Das wusste ich nicht.
Sieht man auch nicht. Ich hab gedacht,
das ist irgendein Service von der Stadt, weil es halt auch
mitten auf dem Willy-Brandt-Platz steht.
Ich hab halt gedacht, das ist ein Service von der Stadt
für Leute, die da rumlaufen,
Rentner, Touristen,
whatever, die Zeile ist ja auch nur um die Ecke,
wenn die sich mal abkühlen wollen.
Und mein nächster Gedanke war halt, okay,
funktioniert das denn? Wir sind hier im Bahnhofsviertel.
Wahrscheinlich
sitzt dann da irgendwie Gott um die Welt
vom Bahnhofsviertel wieder drin.
Und wofür es gedacht ist, geht gar nicht.
Aber es ist ja gar nicht dafür gedacht.
Das wusste ich zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht.
Natürlich mussten sich dann alle wieder aufspielen,
was für bessere Menschen sie sind.
Aber es ist halt Twitter.
Dieses als bessere Menschen aufspielen, das ärgert mich sonst.
Dass einer was dagegen sagt,
ja, das ist mein...
gibt Schlimmeres.
Aber war schon wieder ganz besonders
So, habe ich jetzt alles beantwortet
Hier aus dem Chat
Das macht DevPod automatisch
Ich habe gestern heute
Einen To-Do-List-Package
Für nvm-config gebaut
Was soll ich mir darunter vorstellen?
Du hast dir eine To-Do-Liste gebaut, was du in deine nvm-Config einbauen willst, oder was?
What?
Ja, ja, Debian hat kein sudo standardmäßig.
Und es gibt viele Container-Images, die standardmäßig kein sudo haben.
Weil normalerweise willst du ja in Container-Images nicht sudoen müssen.
In Container-Images, also Container-Images sind ja normalerweise dafür gedacht,
Du startest eine Anwendung in der Config, wie du sie haben willst und fertig.
Container Images sind nicht unbedingt für interaktives Login gedacht, standardmäßig.
Deswegen installiere ich da, guck mal, ich meine, ich installiere doch hier auch God und die Welt nach hier, da.
Temux, Hardtop, sonst was, Bash Completion, das ist halt, VGAT, Curl, das ist da halt alles nicht dabei.
Und Sudo ist auch nicht dabei, aber Sudo ist halt ganz praktisch,
Weil wenn du interaktiv im Container arbeitest, willst du nicht unbedingt immer als Root arbeiten, weil viele Sachen nicht gescheit funktionieren als Root.
Ich benutze Nix Package Manager. Ich habe das, wobei hier habe ich es gar nicht gesehen.
Ich habe das installiert auf den meisten Kisten, aber ich benutze es selten.
Das Ding ist nämlich, an sich ist der Nix Package Manager richtig nice.
das problem ist nur dass du sachen die über den mix package manager installiert werden
teilweise nicht unabhängig von nix gescheit verwenden kannst also du musst dann du musst
dann mit nix eine shell starten beispielsweise das alles richtig gesetzt ist dass die tools
sich untereinander finden und so das nicht so schön bei manchen tools geht bei manchen nicht
Also
Das ist so halbe halbe
Es ist geil, dass es so viele Packages gibt
Aber manchmal bringt es dir auch nichts
Aber gerade für das Containerzeug
Finde ich es richtig nice, um Kram nachzuinstallieren
Wenn aber halt auch nicht alles geht
Ja, so sieht es aus
Und wie gesagt, ich installiere mir ja alles nach, was ich brauche
Gut
Das AF-Klo braucht einen Rust-Rewrite
Ja, ich weiß, das ist ein bisschen laggy, oder?
Das ist halt eine Schleife in Bash
Das laggt halt ein bisschen, kann man nichts machen
Welche ZSH-Theme benutzt du?
Ähm
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Also das ist Starship, der Prompt und der Theme.
Starship-Tommel.
Jaja, ist gut.
Das hier ist mein Theme.
Frag mich nicht mal, was ich da gemacht habe, aber es funktioniert.
Das ist übrigens auf GitHub, falls du dir das angucken willst und analysieren möchtest, was ich da gemacht habe.
Weil so genau weiß ich das auch nicht mehr.
Also ich verwende Starship als Prompt.
Und das ist halt die Config für das Theme.
Ja, das habe ich von irgendwo copy-pasted.
Ja, ich verwende weder Elm noch Highskill oder sonst was.
Und dann sieht das halt so aus.
Was ich tatsächlich angepasst habe
Und was ich auch
Wo ich auch sehr von überzeugt bin
Muss ich mal sagen
Ist
Wo sieht man es denn hier? Ich sehe es gar nicht
Okay Chat
Ah hier Line Break, das da
Da bin ich auch sehr überzeugt von
Ich bin der Meinung, zweizeiliger Prompt
Ist besser als
Einzeiliger Prompt
Gibt ja viele Leute, die schwören drauf
Hier so einzeiliger Prompt
Das Ding ist aber
Ich kann es euch auch sagen
Warum ich einen zweizeiligen Prompt besser finde
Zum Beispiel, denkt jetzt mal hier hin
Ich gehe jetzt nach
Repos, Linux, Crypto
Da gehe ich hin
So, guckt mal
Jetzt ist hier so viel
Ist schon von diesem Prompt weg
Wenn ich jetzt erst hier tippen würde
Müsste ich in jeder Zeile, wenn ich das Verzeichnis wechsle
müsste ich in jeder Zeile an einer anderen Stelle
gucken, wo es losgeht.
Und ich habe, guckt euch das an, ich habe ja im Prinzip
nur noch so viel Platz, um hier was zu tippen.
Und bei einem zweizeiligen Prompt
habe ich so viel Platz, hier was zu tippen.
Also insofern, ich
schwöre auf zweizeiligen Prompt.
Beste.
Zweizeiliger Prompt.
Größer einzeiliger Prompt.
Könnt ihr mir ja mal sagen, wie ihr das seht.
Aber für mich ist das, liegt das auf der Hand.
Windows, ja, kommt man manchmal nicht drumherum.
Chat, ich muss mir noch ein Wasser holen.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Ich bin nicht wirklich auf Klo, aber...
Es sollte tun, ja?
Ich bin in einer Minute wieder da.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
So, bin am Start.
Beschäftigst du dich schon mit Web3-Kryptoprogrammierung?
Tatsächlich ein bisschen, aber je nachdem wie man es nimmt
Ich beschäftige mich damit, weil ich auf der Arbeit seit Anfang an in einem Krypto-Blockchain-Projekt mit dabei bin
Und ich habe dafür schon ein paar kleine Sachen programmiert
Allerdings weniger Sachen, die direkt was mit Blockchain und Krypto zu tun haben
Sondern hauptsächlich fürs Monitoring
Allerdings Monitoring von Blockchain-Krypto-Software
sowas wie, wie alt ist
die letzte Block-ID
und solche Geschichten.
Aber du kannst mich dazu nichts
fragen. Von den internen Sachen
habe ich nur so viel Ahnung, wie nötig.
Machst du
auf der Arbeit viele verschiedene...
Ups, Moment, jetzt
war ich irgendwie am Mikrofon rumgespackt.
Mache ich sehr viele verschiedene Sachen.
Oh.
Ich habe sehr viele verschiedene Services,
für die ich zuständig bin.
Aber Sachen...
Also ich würde jetzt
nicht sagen, dass das
so viele
verschiedene Sachen sind. Ich mache ganz viel
YAML-Config für Terraform.
Ansible, Gedöns
für Automatisierungssachen.
GitLab CI
config also ich bin halber jammer engineer
ja viele verschiedene themen sind tatsächlich also ich hab ich hab das
war überlegen ich bin zuständig für das war überlegen
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, glaube ich.
Ich glaube für fünf Services.
Ein Service ist bei uns quasi die Beschreibung für eine Anwendung, wenn man es so will.
Ja, es muss aber nicht zwangsläufig eine Anwendung sein.
Also eine Funktionalität, könnte man sagen.
zu einem Service gehört dann
1 bis x
Linux VMs
oder ein Kubernetes Cluster
oder eine Datenbank in der Cloud oder whatever
und die sind alle dafür da, um halt
einen bestimmten Service anzubieten.
5 Stück habe ich da.
Mal größere, mal kleinere.
So.
Pusten stellst.
Nice, das Tool auf GitHub gefunden.
Ah, Moment, das wurde geblockt.
Du darfst das,
du darfst das aber posten.
Gucken wir uns mal an, was das hier ist.
Why is it running?
Trace any browsers, port, container
or file back to where it started.
Okay, das ist in der Tat ganz cool.
Die Frage ist,
gibt es das
mittlerweile unter Debian?
was kurz checken docker run baby an fixie wir wollen nix mountain
wie heißt dieses ding
app search wird wird oder so ne name gibt es nicht
Hä, ich tu mir immer schwer...
Ich tu mir immer schwer mit Tools, die es halt nicht in den Standard-Repos gibt.
Also für größeren Einsatz, ja.
Weil, warum bei mir lokal ein Port offen ist oder was läuft, juckt mich meistens gar nicht so sehr.
In der Regel, weil ich selbst gestartet habe.
Auf dem Server interessiert mich das oftmals.
so nach dem Motto, wer hat denn hier wieder irgendwas verkackt?
Ah, okay, da ist ein Wim offen,
der den Datenbankdump geöffnet hat, deswegen hat
der Server so wenig RAM.
Ja, sowas, dafür war es, aber da gibt es das halt nicht.
Aber an sich, coole Sache.
Gibt es das hier
im Arch
User Repo?
Wie drrrr gibt es? Okay.
Ist in Debian
unstable. Das heißt, wenn wir
Glück haben, kommt der Kram
auch bald mal irgendwann
in testing
wobei das ja lange dauern kann wenn ob und wann sachen von unstable in testing
kommen
so jetzt habe ich euch das mit den containern gezeigt jetzt würde ich gerne
mal dazu übergehen,
mich mit Python zu beschäftigen.
Weil der Sinn
und Zweck ist eigentlich, ich will
ein bisschen Python CLI
programmieren lernen, also wie man Python
Command Line Tools machen kann. Python.
Kommando Zeilen Tools.
Wir haben gestern rausgefunden,
wie man Python Tools relativ
gut als Single Self-Contained
Binary bauen kann.
Richtig nice Tool.
Die sind nicht so geil wie Go Binaries
portable aber sie sind portable genug sie laufen sie laufen auf jedem gelb c basierten linux seit
ubuntu 12 04 uv oder pipp weder noch selbst content champ wir haben das so gemacht wir zeigen
Many Linux
Und
Ja, ich hätte
Wir bauen uns nachher noch ein Docker-File
Um das zu machen, ja
Ja, das ist UV, das habe ich damals angelegt
Aber das Kompilieren haben wir nicht damit gemacht
Das Kompilieren haben wir nicht damit gemacht
Das haben wir mit NuitK
Oder so gemacht, hieß das
Oh, der RfProgrammer ist wieder am Start
Oh ne, jetzt hab ich's ver...
Nein, jetzt hab ich's verraten
MonkaS
Okay, jetzt müssen wir erstmal
Ein bisschen Python-Moha aufbauen
Weil der Chat hat mir gestern gesagt
UV ist das Ding schlechthin
Was die ganzen Python-Hackermans
Verwenden, um neue Projekte anzulegen
Und ich hab davon, ehrlich gesagt
Kein Plan
deswegen machen wir das jetzt mal also wir brauchen
bei project ist einfach nur peinlich das fehlt auch mit pip was es geht auch mit pip
Kann man mit UV auch PIP installieren? Ja, es gibt UV-PIP-Install und sowas.
Wir müssen uns jetzt erstmal zum Entwickeln einen, initial mal einen Container bauen, weil ich habe noch keine Projekt-Templates für Python.
Also machen wir mal hier
MKDir
Oder ne, wir kopieren einfach was
Wir kopieren mal das
Ähm, keine Ahnung
Das
Go-Template
Okay
So, also
Was braucht man denn da unbedingt?
Dockerfile-Base
Juckt mich nicht
Dockerfile-Base ist Dockerfile-Base
Hier, da müssen wir rein
Da müssen wir rein
Das ist jetzt das Template für das Projekt
Das muss ich auch nur einmal machen, dann habe ich es für immer
So, Dockerfile
Also, das ist ja doch sehr übersichtlich
Also, was braucht man denn
In einem Python-Container
Was ist denn da
UV braucht man, oder?
uv wir probieren das mal aus also wir machen mal ein docker run trick sie
wieder ein aktuelles pein das hat das habe ich mir fast schon gedacht also uv
brauchen wir uv install weil weil weil wir haben kein
Wir haben ja noch kein aktuelles Python und Pip und so.
Oh, jetzt ist natürlich die Frage.
Kann ich mit dem System Pip UV installieren und dann UV benutzen, um mir weitere Pythons zu installieren?
Oh, das ist Sixhead.
Okay, wartet mal.
Upt, Install, Python.
Was muss man da installieren?
Pip?
Nicht Ip.
Pip.
Pip?
Ne, Python 3 Pip, okay.
Das muss man installieren.
Und dann...
Okay, das installiert erstmal das halbe Internet mit.
Warum auch immer.
Okay, und dann kann man sagen, Pip install UV.
Pip install... geht nicht.
install package system ist drei ab install
was zum teufel ist welts von mir
Ist denn UV
Ab Search
UV ist es denn
Ist denn UV hier überhaupt
UFU
UV ist da nicht
Nicht starkmäßig bei Debian dabei oder
Was
UV. Ich hab kein
VNV. Ich will auch kein VNV. Ich will das
global installieren. Kann man das
nicht irgendwie forcen?
Ich brauch das ja nur, um das
zu bootstrappen.
Okay, hier.
Break System Packages. Bam.
Perfekt.
Perfekt. Das
klingt schon nach einer guten Grundlage für
einen Entwicklungscontainer. Install UV
Break System Packages.
Genauso will ich das haben.
Okay, und wie funktioniert der Rest jetzt?
Was kann man...
Okay, wir müssen mal das Docker-File...
Also.
Ich könnte Python natürlich auch mit Nix-Packages installieren.
Das wäre natürlich auch eine Idee.
Moment, das machen wir einfach.
Wartet mal, das checken wir jetzt einfach, ob das funktioniert.
Sekunde, ich habe doch noch...
Ich hab da noch dieses Rust-Ding hier.
Moment.
Ich starte mal meinen Rust-Container.
Und installiere mir dann mit Nix Packages mal was nach.
Na, mein Plan war ja, Chillfreak, mein Plan war, ich installiere mir Pip im System.
Mit Pip installiere ich UV.
Mit UV installiere ich dann die neueste Python-Version.
Das war der Plan.
Wenn ich das natürlich auch einfach über Nix machen kann,
ist ja noch besser.
Nix N für Nix Packages Go.
Achso, so mit Go.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
So, da sind wir.
Das können wir, by the way,
trusten.
Ich will die IDE gar nicht.
IDE, geh weg.
Weg.
IDE. Weiche
IDE. Lass dich closen.
Und der X.
Hätte ich jetzt X-Kill gemacht.
Aber sowas gibt es ja unter Wayland nicht.
Oder weiß ich gar nicht. Gibt es? Gibt es?
Was ist das Gegenstück von X-Kill unter Wayland?
X-Kill?
Was? Kill X?
Äh, gibt es nicht.
X-Wayland-Kill?
Äh.
Filbo, ich weiß es nicht genau.
Also,
wahrscheinlich ist es am besten,
ich mache das alles über UV, oder?
Ah, keine Ahnung.
Okay, nix Packages.
Machen wir mal hier, Python. Mal gucken, was dann rauskommt.
Äh.
Okay, drei.
Ne, ich glaube, das backt ziemlich rum.
Ich glaube, das wird ziemlich rumbacken, wenn ich das über Nix mache.
Weil das Ding ist, Nix installiert halt das Package.
Und die ganzen Dependencies.
Das Problem ist jetzt, wenn ich das jetzt hier starte, dann weiß das Nix von diesen Packages.
Ich müsste das in der Nix-Shell starten.
Und das ist dann, ne, das ist glaube ich nicht so gut, wenn ich das über Nix mache.
Ne, ich bleib mal bei meinem Plan.
Pip uv break system packages.
Docker-File.
Run.
Okay, so, das haben wir.
Nix go brauchen wir bestimmt nicht.
Also pip install uv break system packages.
Okay, und wenn man jetzt uv installiert hat, dann kann man, wie geht das dann weiter?
Python.
uv init in deinem Projekt Directory.
Ach so.
UV-Self-Update?
What?
Ah!
Wir können aber...
Wir können UV...
Nix...
Nix-Package.
UV können wir über Nix-Packages installieren.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich die beste Idee
Wir installieren UV über Nix Packages
Oder auch nicht
Ich weiß nicht, wie wir das am besten machen
Wir können auch einfach
Komm, wir machen jetzt, bevor wir uns jetzt lange damit
PipX
Was ist denn pipx?
Uptinstall
pipx
Doch, das geht über das Skript, aber ich pipe immer ungern irgendwelche Skripts rein.
Pipx geht auch.
Okay, was ist jetzt der Unterschied zwischen
pipx und pip.
Okay, jetzt bin ich
verwirrt. Ich starte nochmal den Debian-Container neu.
Update. Ich bin
halt nicht der Python-Checker, ne?
Upt install
pipx. Ups.
Pipx.
Der macht einen virtuellen Mann.
Okay. Pipx
install uv.
das ist pip und vn für einen tool aha also machen so
jetzt sagt er mir install package uv install using python 3 13
dies apps annau global available uv stimmt doch überhaupt nicht lügt doch
nicht ja da ich doch gut local bin ist not in
path environment ja ach aber ich kann ich kann das jetzt hier drüber starten
was selbst update selbst ist auch die welt binaries und so am ong ks ok
scheiß drauf beim köln kein bock mehr wird es wird einfach es wird einfach
geparkt doch gut ist einmal installiert easy heißt im endeffekt beim update
abt install abt install ist also jetzt habe ich hoffe das
gecheckt dass ich jetzt getippt habe
da sind wir uv ach so okay source local bin
Okay, naja.
So, und jetzt sage ich
UV, Python,
oder was? UV?
Wie geht das jetzt weiter? Gar nicht.
Es reicht doch eigentlich, wenn ich UV habe, oder?
Ja.
Und danach kann ich den Rest damit machen.
Okay, gut.
Ne, ne, das reicht ja.
UV und gut ist.
Das heißt, mehr brauche ich doch eigentlich gar nicht.
Das Sourcen könnte ich noch machen.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Update.
Hier, das Sourcen.
Das könnte ich noch irgendwie da reinschreiben vielleicht.
Dass ich das in die...
In die Basher C reinhaue.
Das könnte man auch machen.
Also im Endeffekt.
So.
Und jetzt.
Source.
Das da.
Ähm.
Echo.
Ja.
Gut.
Nach.
Da stand doch, dass das in der neuen Shell automatisch drin ist.
Ja, aber nicht.
Okay.
Dann probieren wir das mal.
Schauen wir mal.
Gucken wir mal.
Keine Ahnung.
Ups.
Dann probieren wir das mal.
Also.
Templates.
Also vielleicht sollten wir noch ein paar Sachen hier rauslöschen.
Falls da noch Sachen drin sind, die
irgendwie was mit Go zu tun haben.
Ja.
Hier App. Da ist ja noch
Go Mod.
Main Go. Da machen wir jetzt einfach
main.py
Lassen wir leer.
Scheiß drauf.
Hauptsache die Datei ist da.
Touch. Main.
Punkt Pi.
Okay, sonst.
Ja, Run und Build und so
brauchen wir jetzt auch nicht.
Das kann ich ja irgendwann einmal anpassen.
Ah, juckt jetzt nicht.
Okay, also.
Dann Cookie Cutter Templates Python.
Und dann mal schauen, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Could not be found.
Warum?
Achso, weil ich dumm bin.
Weil ich im falschen Verzeichnis bin.
Projektname.
Pi
CLI Champ.
Besser.
Pi CLI Champ.
So, und wenn ich jetzt das
richtig gemacht habe, dann...
Ah, wir müssen eine Sache noch anpassen.
Und zwar
mein Connection-Skript.
Und zwar wollen wir hier noch
zur Auswahl haben...
Das muss ich ins Base...
Pied Charm.
Okay.
Was habe ich falsch gemacht?
Gibt es Pied Charm nicht?
unknown instruction curl
what
the unknown instruction curl
curl ist doch installiert
was ist das
warum geht das jetzt nicht
curl
ist es doch
the unknown instruction curl
ach da steht nicht run davor
Okay.
Pepega.
Da hätte ich ja selbst drauf kommen können,
dass das nicht geht.
Run muss davor.
Gut. So, jetzt noch einmal.
Pycharm.
Das sieht doch schon besser aus jetzt.
So, jetzt kann er initial mal seinen Container hier starten
Moment mal, habe ich PyCharm überhaupt installiert?
Ich bin mal gespannt, was der jetzt macht, wenn ich PyCharm nicht installiert habe
Er extractet irgendwas?
Starting PyCharm
through JetBrains Gateway?
Habe ich PyCharm
doch installiert?
Scheint so.
Nee, VS Code Fallback brauche ich jetzt nicht.
Auf VS Code...
Wobei ich glaube, chat verwendet jemand von euch Python in Visual Studio Code zum Python programmieren?
Ich glaube das ist auch echt brauchbar.
Oder seid ihr nur hardcore Neo-Wim User?
Alles was nicht auf der Home-Row liegt, existiert nicht.
Was ich richtig krass finde, ist ich gucke auf YouTube Videos von jemand, der macht so...
Ich sag mal so
Defops, aus dem Defops-Bereich Videos.
Und der hat so ein
wirres Tastatur-Setup, wo ich mich
jedes Mal frage, wie kann man so arbeiten?
Guck mal, warte mal, ich zeige euch das mal kurz.
Boah, Alter, meine ganze Kiste
ist ausgelastet wegen dem Jetbrains-Ding.
trial
Geh weg
Da haben wir unsere idee am start
Wir haben unsere app die müssen wir nochmal extra extra öffnen hier drin weil das backt teilweise rum
Du magst das nicht mit ki bauen okay
Ja, heute bauen wir nix mit KI
Ey, ey, sogar die Maus leckt, Alter
Leute
Alter, was jetzt?
Ich glaub, meine Kiste hat sich aufgehängt
Durch, durch
Peitscham
Ja?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Moment, Moment.
Ich beende das mal hier.
Alter, was passiert hier?
Was passiert hier?
Ich glaube, der hat ein paar Probleme, weil ich nur 8 GB RAM habe in dem Mini-PC.
Chat, ich glaube, der ist dead.
Ich glaube, der ist dead.
Ich glaube, ich muss rebooten.
Ich glaube,
da macht nichts mehr.
Also, ich versuche,
ich versuche den Graben...
Okay, close and stop. Jawohl, jawohl.
Don't suggest again.
Oh, ich habe es geschafft, Leute.
Es ist aus.
Okay.
wir betreten jetzt das server ich konnte noch nicht mal rüber switchen
ok nochmal vielleicht geht es jetzt wenn ich noch mal starte das war kurz hier
das ganze dass jemand das ganze beobachten
alles wird aber echt knapp mit dem ramm an dem moment das ist der dass sogar der
fucking Swap ist voll.
Sogar mein Swap ist voll, Alter.
Ich habe zu wenig RAM in der Kiste drin.
Scheiße.
Ich habe zu wenig RAM.
Swap voll.
F.
Wobei jetzt geht es irgendwie komischerweise.
Keine Ahnung, warum es jetzt funktioniert.
Hallo?
Geil.
Workspaces
App.
Swindle.
Das hat glaube ich weniger was
mit dem Python-Projekt zu tun.
Mehr mit PyCharm.
Okay, es läuft.
Leute, ich muss unbedingt mir nochmal ein 8GB-RAM-Riegel
kaufen. Dann habe ich 16.
Dann ist das kein Problem mehr.
Aber 8GB ist halt doch ein bisschen
wenig.
Max, hast du das schon gesehen?
Was ist denn das?
Ohne...
Äh, ja.
Aber nicht on stream.
Und ich hab da noch durchgeskippt.
So, ich hoffe...
Okay, das sieht jetzt nicht wirklich viel besser aus.
Aber es sieht so aus, als würde es laufen wenigstens, okay?
Also, dann müssen wir uns jetzt mal angucken
Wie man das mit UV macht
Also ich hab jetzt hier eine Main.py
Das bringt uns hier alleine jetzt noch nicht allzu viel
Also, wie installiere ich denn jetzt hier was?
Also ne, warte mal, UV hab ich ja schon
Guck mal, UV, da ist es
Nice
Okay, also jetzt geh ich hier rein und sag
UV init
Ne, hier, nach App geh ich rein, ne
Punkt.
Initialize Project App.
Sehr gut.
Hat auch einen gescheiten Namen.
So, was haben wir denn da jetzt zu bieten?
Read me, Alter. Geh weg.
Python Version 3.13.
Ach, da gibt es jetzt nochmal
einen Source drin, oder was?
Okay.
Okay, verstehe, verstehe.
Da ist Main.
Aber da gibt es nochmal Source.
Warum ist...
Nochmal App.
Jetzt, jetzt übertreib halt.
App, Source, App.
Appception.
Komm.
Wir machen das.
Wir machen das den UV-Way.
Was steht denn in diesem Pi-Project jetzt eigentlich drin?
Add your description here.
Read me MD.
Die hab ich aber gerade gelöscht, die Readme-MD.
UV-Build, UV-Backend.
Okay.
So, und jetzt haben wir hier...
Ein Git-Report ist nicht angelegt, oder?
Was, ich hab kein Git standardmäßig drauf installiert?
Och geil, sudo apt install.
Kein Shit.
haben wir nicht aber auch okay hat das hier in den gipfel ist aber auch wurscht braun und also
app sondern das haben wir hier source und dann noch mal app alter warum und dann in it in it
Pie. Print Hello World
from App. Okay, alles klar.
Kann man jetzt sowas machen wie
UV Run?
Nein.
Touch.
Der will wirklich eine Read Me MD haben,
sonst geht er nicht.
Fail to hardlink files.
Falling back to full copy.
Äh, what?
Was?
Du willst von
mir
Also, Source App Init oder was?
Ne.
Und wie soll das jetzt funktionieren?
Dev Main.
UV Run App?
Ah
Kann ich auch sagen
uvrun.
Ne, das wäre jetzt zu einfach.
Okay, uvrun-app
Das ist ja schon mal ganz gut.
So, und wenn ich jetzt ein aktuelleres
Python verwenden will, dann mache ich
uv, Python wahrscheinlich
install
latest
Geht das?
Nee.
Help.
To be supported.
Hier.
Kann ich einfach sagen 3 und dann installiert er mir das Neueste?
Nee.
Ah ja, okay.
So installiert er mir das Neueste. Sehr gut.
Und jetzt hat er es installiert.
Ist halt die Frage,
wie
aktiviert man das jetzt?
List?
What?
Okay.
Ja, aber das muss man doch nicht von Hand editieren, oder?
Man kann auch bestimmt sagen, activate oder sowas.
Pin?
Pin!
Oder?
Soll ich es so sagen?
Ah ja, okay.
Sehr fein, nice.
UV-Run-App.
Und das runnt er jetzt?
auch in python 3 14 ja
ok peyton haut und version gibt es auch bestimmt irgendwas mit den
Python Version. Genau.
So, gehen wir mal in unsere IDE.
App.
Äh, hallo?
Will nicht.
Open.
Hallo?
Wie, da ist nichts drin? Willst du mich verarschen?
Ah, okay.
Der will mich verarschen.
Source.
Init.
Okay, das müssen wir mal ein bisschen größer machen.
Oh nein!
Please, nicht zu viel machen.
Ich habe zu wenig RAM.
UV-Run Python.
Ah.
Ah ja, cool.
Aber man kann das doch bestimmt auch printen hier.
Guck mal hier.
Import Sys.
Also das muss ich dann hier oben machen.
Import Sys
Und dann Print Sys Version
Jetzt machen wir erstmal die Font Size
Ein bisschen größer
Font Size
Ja
Change mit dem Mausrad
Okay
So jetzt sieht man wenigstens ein bisschen was
Heißt im Endeffekt
Wenn ich jetzt das mache
Sagt er mir 3.14.7
Exzellent
Genau so will ich das haben
So, dann wollen wir mal
Dann bauen wir eine kleine CLI App
Wie gesagt, ich bin nicht der große Python Checker
Wir machen jetzt
Wir machen jetzt wirklich mal ein paar ganz simple Geschichten
Wir machen jetzt mal
Eine
Fangen wir mal an
Wie übergebe ich denn der App
Command Line Arguments
Wahrscheinlich so
wahrscheinlich muss ich so machen
gibt es
so was wie Python
Arcs oder so was
Arcs
ArcV
bringt das jetzt was
ha
Magic
ok ja hier sieht man es doch
Minus Minus Version würde übergeben
und das Minus Minus kann weg.
Also der, okay.
Ja, nice. Okay.
Genau sowas will ich haben.
Gut.
Also, dann machen wir jetzt mal
ein, also Main brauchen wir nichts.
Wir müssen jetzt erstmal gucken, wie man Command Lines
passt. Also ich will sowas machen.
Machen wir mal
ein Beispiel mit
mit einer
simplen Hello World Webseite,
die ausgeliefert wird oder sowas.
Also sowas wie...
App...
Surf oder so.
Ja, aber sowas.
Der Chat hat mir gesagt,
ich soll dafür
Klick verwenden.
Hat mir der Chat gestern erzählt.
Kann aber auch sein, dass...
Ne, das ist was ganz anderes.
Was zum...
M
Ich check jetzt gerade nicht genau, was Klick ist.
Ist das denn jetzt ein Command-Line-Parser?
Oder ein Tool für Color-Konsolen-Ausgabe?
Oder was, wie, wo?
Arkpasa ist das.
Warum schreiben die das hier nicht einfach hin?
Okay.
Ist Klick taugt das?
Also ist das sinnvoll zu verwenden?
Klick.
Ich kenne mich im Python Ökosystem
überhaupt nicht aus.
Return File
HTML Pfad.
Ja, das wird ja nochmal.
Oh nein, es hängt wieder.
Mein RAM ist voll.
Ich brauche mehr RAM, Leute.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Chat, Chat, Chat, Chat. Wir machen jetzt mal eine Sache.
Wir machen jetzt erstmal eine Sache.
Memory shortage avoided.
Oh, geil. Jetzt hab ich meine IDE verreckt.
Top.
Wir brauchen mehr Swap.
Ich hab
zu wenig Swap, okay?
FastAPI
Typer.
Wie viele von dem Kram gibt es denn eigentlich hier?
Klick.
17.000 Sterne.
19.000 Sterne.
Alter.
Die wollen es aber mal wissen hier.
Ja.
Create a file.
Main Pi.
Dev Main.
Name Str.
Rind.
Hello Name.
Hyper Command?
Warum brauche ich dafür ein fucking eigenes Command?
Ich will doch kein eigenes Command dafür irgendwie.
Hä?
Das ist...
Das ist Six Head, ja.
Ach jetzt kann...
Ach jetzt...
Ach so, jetzt verstehe ich das.
Ach, jetzt verstehe ich es.
Okay.
Das ist quasi so
Typer Main, Typer Run.
Okay, macht Sinn.
Ja, ja, okay.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Ja, das können wir gleich ausprobieren.
Vorher, ich brauche mehr Swap, Leute.
Swap.
Swap off, Swap on.
Ich glaube, ich habe seit den letzten 10 Jahren nicht mehr Swap erweitern müssen.
Wo kommt denn das überhaupt her bei mir?
Wo kommt denn das überhaupt her?
Habe ich das in der FS-Tab stehen?
Temperfest!
Ne.
Wo kommt denn das überhaupt?
Hier war Cash.
Nee, BTFS.
Wo kommt denn mein Swap überhaupt her?
Äh.
Check ich jetzt gar nicht.
Also, zu Zeiten, wo ich noch öfter Swap verwendet habe,
dann stand das bei DF.
Vielleicht muss man dafür...
Vielleicht muss man dafür gut sein?
Swap on.
Ja, das kenne ich.
Summary.
Aha, es gibt sogar ein Summary dafür.
Dev Zram.
Aha.
Und?
Aber woher weiß der denn?
Bei einem Start?
Also wenn das nicht in der FS-Tab drin steht, woher weiß der denn bei einem Start, dass der das überhaupt mounten soll oder überhaupt benutzen soll?
Das ist ja...
Big Brain.
System D Swap.
Hab ich noch nie verwendet, gibt's nicht.
das war jetzt mal
da lernt man was ja
modprobe ztm ztl der
fc sei es mk swap juklia priority swap on disk ok auf geht's wobei wir da sei es machen
war kann man doch so was reinschreiben wie viel wie viel hatte ich jetzt
7 da machen wir machen wir 16 gig die weiße resource busy
erstmal mal gespannt ob das jetzt überhaupt funktioniert oder ob ich zu wenig rahmen
habe wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich scheiße
ok browser zu ich muss das erst mal ausschalten
Swap off
Def
Def, Z-RAM, okay
Oh, please, please, einfach funktionieren
Okay, es hat funktioniert, nice
So, und jetzt, und jetzt, wie war das jetzt?
Na geil, jetzt muss ich den Firefox
Nein, jetzt kackt mir das ab, weil ich den Firefox
wieder aufmachen muss
Okay
Und jetzt
So
Was hab ich gesagt, 16 Gig?
Immer noch nicht
modpro-r
zram
is in use
lsof dev zram
was?
okay, äh
wie kann man das resizen?
kann man das resizen irgendwie?
resize
Z-RAM.
Wie kann ich?
Sehr gut.
Ah, Swapping das Faktor juckt mich nicht.
Ja, woher soll ich denn wissen,
wie
System D Z-RAM Setup,
woher soll ich denn wissen, wie
CacheUS diesen Krempel eingerichtet hat.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
ETC, System
System D, Krepp,
ZRAM.
Naja, nix. Das wäre ja auch deutlich zu einfach.
System CTL
ZRAM.
Naja.
Status.
Swap.
Swap Target.
Ich würde einfach eine Swap-File erstellen.
Die Mountain mit Swap On.
Ja, aber man muss diesen Campel doch resizen können.
Also irgendwo muss das doch drinnen stehen.
Dass ich jetzt beim nächsten Start das nicht nochmal neu machen muss.
Hash IOS ZRAM.
ZRAM.
Extend.
How to increase ZRAM.
Okay, bam.
Haben wir es.
ETC
ZRAM Generator.
Was es nicht alles gibt,
Mann. Ne. Shit, doch.
Ist es nicht.
File for Config.
Moment. Okay, ich muss das
doch mal lesen. Ne, FHTAP ist nix.
The config file ist etc...
Ja, ist es nicht.
Lügt. Lügt nicht.
Aha.
Okay.
Da haben wir es doch.
Z-Ramster. Ach, hier.
Okay.
Kann man sowas hier machen? Mal 2?
Geht das? Kann das rechnen?
Nee, oder?
Das geht!
Krass! Ey, das ist ja geil!
Ram mal 2?
Das ist ja richtig Big Brain.
Das ist ja richtig schlau, das Ding.
So, muss man jetzt nochmal neu starten?
Nee, oder?
Man kann doch bestimmt...
Restart Z-RAM.
System CTL.
Nee.
Swap on.
Def.
ZRAM.
Die war jetzt busy.
Okay.
Also das hat sich jetzt so noch nicht resized.
Ich frag wirklich mal ChatGPT.
Restart ZRAM Swap.
Arch Linux hätte ich.
Restart.
System D Z-RAM Setup.
Was für Dinger, Mann.
Und wir haben...
Wir haben mehr Zeit.
Z-RAM.
Kunst.
GG.
Gut.
Das heißt, wir können jetzt auch wieder...
...eine IDE öffnen, ohne dass es komplett abkackt.
Hi Charm.
Können wir uns hier
Können wir uns hier vielleicht noch oben
was einblenden für RAM-Usage.
Aber jetzt, guck mal, jetzt kriegen wir wieder Platz.
Das Zeug frisst schon krass viel RAM, oder?
Wer sagt, dass 14 Gigs für PyChamp reichen?
Niemand.
Oh, Py... Moment.
What the fuck?
Äh.
Moment, jetzt habe ich PyChamp...
doppelt auf.
But why?
Okay, gut.
Da haben wir es.
So, wie viele... Guck mal, jetzt haben wir doch ordentlich RAM frei. Jetzt ist doch alles gut.
Jetzt ist doch alles top. Ordentlich RAM. Wunderbar.
So, wie war das jetzt? UV-Run-App.
Ah ne, wir müssen erst nach App und dann UV-Run-App.
Okay, so, dann machen wir jetzt mal Argument-Parsing.
Also ihr habt gesagt, bevor wir da jetzt irgendwelche komischen Tools verwenden, sollen wir einfach ArcPath verwenden.
Oder wie hieß das, was ihr vor...
Also from ArcPath.
Import Argument Parse.
Example brauchen wir da mal.
ArcPath Tutorial.
Also, die Basics.
Import ArcPars.
Parser gleich ArcPars.
Argument Parser ParsArgs.
Ähm.
Okay.
Easy. Alles klar.
Also.
Import ArcPars.
Können wir schon mal machen.
Gibt es irgendwie was, wie man diese
Imports sortieren sollte? Oder ist das
persönliche Präferenz?
Parser gleich ArcPars.
Argument Parser.
Ja, das machen wir doch dann in Main, ne?
By the way, woher weiß der überhaupt, dass er Main starten soll?
Muss man normalerweise hier nicht dieses komische Konstrukt unten machen?
Wenn Main dann...
Das da, muss man nicht normalerweise sowas hier machen, dass das funktioniert?
Das steht im Pi-Project drin, ne?
Okay, aber das PyProject
Das wird ja nur verwendet
Wenn man
OV benutzt, oder?
Okay, aber später
Später kompiliere ich den Krempel, ja
Und
Okay
Wir kommentieren das mal aus
Nur für den Fall der Fälle, dass wir das nachher brauchen
Python ist ja in dem Fall nicht so pingelig
Wie Go
dass wir hier nur Imports
ne, dass es einen Error gibt, wenn wir
Imports verwenden, die wir
nicht verwenden
dass es dann rummeckert
also gut, Main
so, wie funzt das jetzt?
Parser
Format
Save Actions
Actions on Save
Reformat Code
ok
Ja, weil da kriege ich ja An...
Äh, hallo?
Reformat?
Äh.
Mein Python ist zu blöd dafür.
Warum geht Reformat und Save nicht?
Save?
Actions.
Warum geht das nicht?
Ist das ein Bug?
Oder geht das nicht für Python-Files?
Oder?
Ja, deswegen soll er das ja formaten und save.
Ja, das ist ja gerade der Sinn von Format.
Dass er solche Errors on Save löscht
Weil wenn ich hier hingehe und sag
Reformat
Dann macht er das ja richtig
Und das soll der gefälligst on Save machen
Ja wenn Reformat von Hand ausgeführt
Leute, Leute
Reformat von Hand ausgeführt
Macht das Richtige
Der soll es on Save machen
macht er aber nicht sagt irgendwie da muss man öfters so reformaten auch okay
ach das das kapiert dafür reformat guckt das kapiert dafür reformat das kapiert er
nicht für reformat was auch immer keine ahnung also art pass okay wie geht das jetzt weiter
an recognize commands sagt er dann ja das war es war gleich testen aber das macht minus minus
Aber hier, serve.
Unrecognized arguments, serve.
Moment, usage-h geht angeblich schon.
Ach, guck mal, der macht sogar standardmäßig ein Help-Text.
Das ist doch ganz praktisch.
Das ist ein...
Aber der Formater, wenn ich den von Hand ausführe, macht das doch.
Warum gibt es einen Formater, den ich von Hand ausführe?
Warum ist es ein anderer Formater, wie den, den aber Save ausführt?
warst du in action und safe ja so ok und wie funzt das jetzt
haben wir ein beispiel
Add Argument. Echo.
Chat, ist das ein Fehler oder bin ich zu dumm?
Der sagt, puh, der müsste doch hier Echo machen, dass das funktioniert, oder?
Der legt ja hier ein Kommando Echo an.
Add Argument.
Echo wird zur Variable?
Aber der...
Weil es das Default Argument ist, oder was?
Ah.
Aber...
Hä?
Okay, das ist echt
Six Head.
Okay, das muss ich jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Also.
Parser at Argument Echo.
Position at Arguments.
Achso, das heißt, das erste Argument
das erste Argument
ist dann
das, was in Echo landet. Achso, das will ich ja gar nicht.
Ich will das ja gar nicht. Ich will das quasi so als
Subcommand verwenden.
Das kann das gar nicht, oder?
Subcommands.
Das kann das nicht,
glaube ich.
Arcpass,
Subcommands.
15 Jahre.
Set.
Add subparters.
What?
Okay, das ist
Sixet. Wir verzichten erstmal
auf subcommands.
das, das, da verzichten wir erstmal drauf.
Wir sagen Argument.
Sowas hier.
Ah, das ist gut.
Das machen wir mal hier.
Minus V, minus, minus
Verbose oder sowas. Ach seht ihr,
da kamen mehrere. Action, Count, Default,
also heißt im Endeffekt,
ich kann jetzt sowas machen wie
äh, minus V,
minus VVV, minus
VVV. Okay, das checkt er dann.
Oder minus minus verbos oder so
Verbosity
Minus minus Verbosity
Und dann 5
Oder was
Oder gleich 5 oder ne
Einfach nur, weil da steht ja count
Die folgen
Ach ne, ich müsste es dann mehrfach hinten dran schreiben
So
Ah ok
Aber das ist ja schon mal ganz gut
Das ist ja schon mal das was ich haben will
Letztendlich
Also, machen wir mal minus minus
Keine Ahnung
Minus minus S
Ich will jetzt den Web-Server starten
Web-Server
Action, Count, Default
0, das ist mir egal
Web-Server, Port
8000, Hardcoded Port
Ist ja nur zum
Start Web-Backend
Unser Web-Backend
jetzt nicht, ihr müsst euch da nicht
äh, fuck, was?
Action Store gleich
true?
Was soll das bedeuten?
Das hat gerade Auto
completed, DTF.
So.
Nochmal gucke.
Findet er nicht? Okay.
Minus S kann ich angeben.
Expect one
argument. Echt jetzt?
Ich will einen Flag.
Ich will einen Flag angeben.
Letztendlich. Aber...
Name of Flags?
Wie? Was für ein Argument
expecte das denn?
Eine Option will ich. Ja.
Ich will gar keinen Flag. Das ist richtig.
Ich will eine Option.
Options.
Ja. Was expecte
das denn? Das expecte
ein Argument 1?
Was haben wir denn hier?
Add.
Okay, das ist
Next Level.
Okay, ich dachte eigentlich
Argument Parsers funktionieren alle ähnlich,
aber so kompliziert habe ich es noch nicht gesehen.
Aber wahrscheinlich checke ich es einfach nur nicht.
Also man kann das jetzt hier mehrfach angeben.
Aber ich muss ein Default angeben, oder?
Aber warum soll ich überhaupt
Default angeben.
Arc Pass
Add Option.
How to add options without
any argument.
Store.
Das muss da wirklich hin. Ja, das ist ja Magic.
Wie zum Teufel soll man da drauf kommen?
Das ist komplett
Magic.
Action Store gleich true.
Whatever.
Action Store?
Was gibt's denn da eigentlich?
Was darf man hier bei Action machen?
Nix.
Magic String.
Gibt's da für eine Hilfe,
wenn man da drüber geht oder so irgendwie?
Okay.
Action Store True.
Ah ja.
Ja, aber ich meine, ob man sich hier für Action das anzeigen lassen kann direkt.
Ah, hier kann man das jetzt.
Action gleich, Type Action.
How to convert command line strings to Python objects.
Okay, man muss das wissen, sonst hat man gelitten.
Ich brauche kein LSP.
Das kann mit die IDE schon alles für mich machen.
Das wäre merkwürdig, wenn ich noch ein extra LSP brauche.
So, jetzt haben wir das.
Und jetzt ist die große Preisfrage.
Woher weiß ich jetzt, dass das hier gesetzt ist?
Woher
weiß ich jetzt, dass das gesetzt ist?
Ah!
If Arx!
Also muss ich das hier quasi
Arx?
Jetzt verstehe ich das. Okay.
If Arx...
Ja, gut.
Das ist jetzt halt, weil
dynamisch.
Surf.
Okay, gucken wir mal, ob das funzt.
Ja, funzt.
Okay, nice.
Das...
Ja, das...
Okay, das ist mit dem Reformen von uns nicht so einfach.
Okay, gut.
Verstehe, macht Sinn.
So, jetzt nächste Preisfrage.
Webserver.
Ich will statisches HTML zurückliefern.
Man könnte jetzt sowas wie Flask oder so installieren.
Lassen wir mal.
Gucken wir mal
Default
So, HTTP
Ja, hat er schon importiert
HTTP
Oh, hier, Autocomplete, habt ihr das gesehen, Leute?
Server
What?
Der WSGI-Server-App
Excellent
Starting on board 8018.
Okay.
Ist es schon mal nett.
HTTP Server.
Gibt es nett?
Cannot find reference.
Okay.
Das ist es schon mal nicht.
http server python http servers http server is not recommended for production ja das ist bei uns
alles kein problem weil bei uns funktioniert das alles first try ohne probleme immer so wie
man will da gibt es keine keine eine probleme gibt es damit example
Jawoll.
Ne.
Hier.
SSL? Nein.
Das ist doch irgendeine dumme KI-Seite, oder?
Sehr gut.
Nein!
Was will der überhaupt hier bei App haben?
Ja.
You need to subclass the base
HTTP request handler. What?
Off the docks nochmal.
HTTP server.
One Class.
It creates and listens at the HTTP-Socket.
Also, okay, das habe ich nicht gesehen vorhin.
Also im Prinzip braucht man sowas.
Im Prinzip braucht man sowas.
Also dieses Auto-Complete kannst du schon mal komplett vergessen.
Okay, der Format, da wird mich noch öfters nerven.
Server Class.
Achso, da muss ich dann eine anlegen von.
Wart mal, Chat, gib bitte.
klar ist okay
ah ja
okay okay verstehe
also man muss sowas hier anlegen
heißt im Endeffekt
du hast doch gesagt keine KI
naja zwischendurch wir lassen nichts großartiges von KI erstellen
base http
unresolved request import
geht das hier auch über die
ok sehr gut
html unresolved install import was jetzt nervt man nicht rum hier weit eckel
ja dass das kriegen wir da schon gleich irgendwie hin
Expected size got literal.
Das wird schon funktionieren.
Punch name should be lowercase.
Handler.
Einfach nur so?
Okay.
Aber Server Class ist immer noch nicht richtig.
Ach so, muss...
Ah!
Okay.
Import HTTP Server vom HTTP Server.
Okay, verstehe.
So, jetzt haben wir ein...
Was?
Expected Type?
Any?
Match?
What?
Okay, das funzt trotzdem.
Also heißt es im Endeffekt, wenn ich jetzt sage hier
Curl localhost 8080
dann kriege ich ein empty
reply, weil er übelst am
abkacken ist.
Object of type int has no length.
Okay.
Gucken wir nochmal.
Das ist nicht so einfach.
Also.
Server Class.
HTTP Server.
Server Address Handler Class.
Handler.
Ach so
Ach jetzt verstehe ich das
Okay, aber
Wenn ich das so mache
Ist ja schön und gut
Aber ich brauche ja einen Händler
Dass ich
Einen Web-Request antworten kann
5.
So.
Hier.
Nochmal testen.
A byte object is required, not string.
Okay, also der stört sich jetzt daran, dass hier Kekkel...
Das ist...
Ich hätte mir das simpler vorgestellt, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, ich nehme doch...
Ich nehme doch eine...
B-Kecke.
Das ist was anderes, was?
B?
Was zum...
Was macht das denn?
Ach, das wandelt das in Bytes um.
Okay, das ist cool.
Guck mal, Kekkel,
es funzt.
Was ist, wenn ich hier 8, 6 reinschreibe
und es ist weniger?
Sag mal, kann UV
auch sowas wie reloaden?
UV reload on change?
Geht das?
On change?
Oder sowas?
Watch!
Nee.
Das gibt's nicht, ne?
Äh.
Ne, ne, okay, das gibt's nicht.
Ja, zumindest das an sich funktioniert ja schon mal jetzt.
Okay, zwei.
Also kann ich doch, kann ich jetzt nicht sowas hier machen?
Quasi sowas wie hier, äh, LED?
nee, äh
Moment, verpeisen braucht man gar nichts, oder?
Also ich kann jetzt aber quasi sagen
Content
B-Keckel
und dann kann ich hier sagen
Length
Content. Boah, das müsste doch so funzen.
Und wenn ich do get
sage, checkt das dann auch.
Nee.
Aren't supported
Okay, das muss tatsächlich groß geschrieben werden.
Okay, nice.
Okay, das habe ich gecheckt.
Ja, das kann man schon so lassen.
Da muss man sich ein bisschen dran gewöhnen, aber das ist okay.
Also ich denke mal, normalerweise würde ich dann wirklich irgendein Framework benutzen.
Aber es geht mir jetzt ja einfach darum, mal gesehen zu haben, wie es funktioniert.
Also wir haben eine Command-Line-App, die statisches HTML surft.
So, jetzt kommt das nächste.
Ich will, dass der ein richtig echtes HTML mir surft.
Jetzt nicht ein Embedded String, sondern HTML.
Da hat doch irgendjemand vorhin geschrieben, man kann einfach File benutzen.
Also legen wir mal an unter Source, App.
Ja, wo legt man das jetzt am besten hin?
Ich leg's mal hier hin.
New HTML
Pile
Index
Lulw
So, wie macht man das jetzt?
Wie surft man das?
Pile?
irgendjemand wir fragen wir fragen mal hier doch vorhand jemand geschrieben
weil return file html text ok was auch immer das das so so einfach wird es
wahrscheinlich gehen und wie soll reference file import package file
nein will nichts installieren okay das von strommer so einfach nicht
Aber File klingt ja an sich schon mal nicht verkehrt.
Oder sowas wie OS Read oder sowas.
OS Read.
Äh, ja, ja, ja.
Sys, Sys, Sys Read.
Python Read File.
Easiest way.
15 Jahre.
Komm, Stack Overflow.
Bam.
With Open
SF
Pathlib
Ah, viel besser.
Viel besser.
Ja, Contents.
Content.
Pathfile.
Geht das?
Von welchem
Verzeichnis geht das aus?
Weil...
Okay, wartet mal.
Das geht von dort aus, wo ich UV starte wahrscheinlich, gell?
Content.
Okay, das mag er nicht.
Bot String.
Kann ich da jetzt...
Kann ich jetzt auch irgendwie B davor schreiben oder so?
Ah, ich kann aber bestimmt...
Moment, pass mal auf.
Byte?
Bytes?
Geht das so?
Ah, ne.
Expected type.
Buffer.
Godstring.
Vielleicht, vielleicht.
Buffer?
Aster encode.
Okay.
Python String to Buffer
Open Value Dings
Ja, das weiß ich
Read
Read Byte
Oh, das ist Six Head
Das ist Six Head
Aber das geht so nicht ohne weiteres, oder?
Expected Buffer Kunst
Okay, so schlau ist er
So schlau ist er
Ist hier was?
Ah, Encode.
Okay.
Der nimmt standardmäßig wahrscheinlich UTF-8 oder sowas.
So, jetzt wird
er wahrscheinlich gleich meckern.
Dass es das nicht gibt.
So, das heißt,
der guckt
von dem Verzeichnis
absteigend,
wo ich drinnen bin.
Jetzt können wir natürlich Trick 17 machen.
Mal was gucken.
Guck mal, der weiß ja hier an dem VNBinApp.
What?
Okay, vergiss es.
Ja, das heißt, ich müsste jetzt im Endeffekt sagen,
Ich will zu
App
Nee, Source
Wahrscheinlich
Aha
Es funzt, Leute
Da ist es
Massive HTML
So, heißt im Endeffekt auch
Wenn ich jetzt
Achso
Moment, habe ich den Port irgendwie weitergeleitet?
Ne, da war ich natürlich zu blöd für.
Ich habe keinen Port weitergeleitet.
In den Container.
Sonst wäre ich da mit dem Browser draufgegangen.
Aber das macht ja nichts.
Ich bin richtig isolated.
Aber passt mal auf.
Jetzt richtig, richtig Six Head Time.
User at...
Wie heißt dieses Ding?
Mich wundert es, dass der Hostname schon mal hier nicht stimmt.
Der Hostname sollte eigentlich ein ordentlicher Hostname sein.
Wir haben DevPodList.
Wir machen SSH-Port forward, ja.
ssh user at
pi
ähm
dev
port
oh ne, ah, da sind wir, nice
so, ssh
minus local port 8080
auf
ne, warte mal, ich mach das so selten
ähm, ne, wir wollen local
port aufmachen, dort auf
local host
Port 8080 weiterleiten.
Genau.
Okay.
Could not request local forwarding.
Warum?
Port is already in use.
Port 8080
ist bei mir in use.
habe ich jetzt
doch kein netzteil drauf
Warum gibt es hier kein Netstat?
Netstat?
Netstat minus Tulpen.
Okay, was muss ich...
Was muss ich da...
Was muss ich dafür installieren?
Net-Utils oder so.
Arch install Netstat.
Pac-Man Net Tools.
Jawohl.
Das wollen wir haben.
Gib ihm.
Yes.
Net Stand minus Tulben.
Port 80.
SSH.
Ah.
Moment.
War ich einfach zu Six Head
und hab mich
selbst outplayed?
Ich glaube, ich hab mich selbst
outplayed.
Ich hab das schon weitergeleitet.
Port 8080.
Das ist defaultmäßig schon weitergeleitet.
Siehst du mal.
Ha.
Also kann ich einfach sagen, Localhost, Port 8080
und ich lande auf meinem Container.
Jetzt habe ich mich aber komplett selbst outsmarted.
Ich habe im Vorfeld schon dran gedacht,
als ich das Template erstellt habe,
dass ich mal Port 8080 haben will.
Das kann ich nicht benutzen.
Das ist schlecht auszusprechen in Deutschland.
Dieses Programm.
Ich weiß, dass das die Alternative
zu Netznet ist.
Aber wenn ich das hier ausspreche,
wenn ich das hier ausspreche im Stream
und dann jemand
meinen Stream reportet
und die hören nur, dass ich das ausspreche
und nicht wissen, dass das ein Netzwerkprogramm ist,
dann werde ich gebannt.
Toss, ja.
Warum, was hat der hier?
Was meckert er hier drüber?
Expected type any any
HTTP Server
Base Request Handler
Match generic type any any
Äh, was?
Was will er eigentlich? Ich meine, gehen tut's doch.
Weil du bei der
Main-Methode Type-Annotations hast
und bei der anderen nicht,
kam das Warning mit Any-Any.
Ah, das heißt, ich brauche hier eine Type-Annotation.
Ne.
Wo brauche ich denn hier eine Type-Annotation?
Da?
Oder wie?
Vielleicht irgendwie Any?
Oder wie für uns?
Ne.
okay keine ahnung ich weiß nicht wie ich type annotations mache
also ich müsste hier reinschreiben was der hier erwartet oder aber aber man
kann doch nicht man kann doch nicht für eine klasse eine type annotation machen
oder?
Also ich kann doch nicht.
Ich kann doch nicht jetzt irgendwie so.
Doch, kann ich? Nee, kann ich nicht.
Das macht ja merkwürdig.
Okay, das schiebe ich mal auf.
Da bin ich gerade noch nicht High IQ genug für,
um das zu checken.
Habe ich einen Händler.
Passt. Gut.
So, nächstes Ding.
Jetzt wird es Pfeifert.
Das ist wahrscheinlich gar nicht so einfach, wie ich mir das vorstelle.
Jetzt habe ich hier eine Index-HTML-Seite.
So.
Die Index-HTML-Seite, die wird ja aktuell vom Filesystem gelesen.
Aber was ist, wenn ich die Index-HTML-Webseite nicht vom Filesystem lesen will,
sondern wenn ich mir, weil das ist ja das Ziel,
eine Self-Contained Binary von dieser Python App dann bauen,
wo die Webseite mit drin ist.
Das heißt, ich müsste das Index HTML
in einen Python String irgendwie konvertieren können.
Kann man mir geistig folgen?
Ja, ich will das nachher bundeln.
Also ich will das nachher kompilieren
dieses Python-Programm. Das haben wir gestern schon gemacht.
Da weiß ich, wie das funktioniert.
Sodass ein Binary rauskommt, was alles enthält,
um diese App zum Laufen,
also was lauffähig, dass die App lauffähig ist.
Ein Binary, was du einfach starten kannst.
Das haben wir gestern rausgefunden, wie das geht.
Das ist gar nicht so kompliziert gewesen.
Und jetzt würde ich gerne das bundeln.
Ja, man kann das mit bundeln,
aber dann müsste ich es hier irgendwie auslesen drinnen.
Kann man nicht?
Okay, jetzt müssen wir mal was ausprobieren.
Kann man nicht sagen?
Könnte man doch...
Könnte so schon fast passen im Bundle.
Muss es mit drin sein.
Das ist komplett cursed, okay.
Dann beschäftige ich mich heute nicht mit Type Annotations.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das funktioniert.
Wollen wir mal die...
die App bundeln.
Also
kompilieren und gucken,
was er sagen würde.
Das machen wir doch jetzt mal.
Also
UV
Pip
Install
Bridge
Kommen wir später noch.
Jetzt
Nuid Car
Ach so.
Moment.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Leute, Leute, nur mal, Moment, ich glaube, ich habe es noch nicht gecheckt.
Wenn ich das mit pip install mache,
ist das dann Dependency vom Projekt?
Das ist dann Dependency von diesem Projekt, ne?
Ich bräuchte sowas wie Def Dependencies bei Node.js.
Gibt es sowas?
Managing Dependencies
Dependency Group
Local Dependencies for Development
Minus Minus Dev
Okay
Also sage ich jetzt hier
Minus Minus Dev
Äh, ne
Weil jetzt habe ich das
Jetzt habe ich das installiert, das Problem ist jetzt
Das ist jetzt quasi Bestandteil
Von diesem
Ne, ist es nicht
Hä?
Moment, wo sind denn jetzt die Dependencies definiert
Überhaupt
Achso
Man muss UV-Add machen
Wenn man das zum, ok, ok
UV-Add-Rich.
Ah.
Okay.
Äh.
Oder auch nicht.
Doch, da unten ist es.
Ah ja, verstehe ich.
Okay.
UV-Pip benutzt einfach nur die aktuelle Python-Version, um da...
Von dem aktuellen Interpreter, um da was zu installieren.
Und mit UV-Add wird es als Dependency hinzugefügt.
Ich verstehe.
Okay.
Und ist denn jetzt das UV-Pip?
Welches Pip ist das denn?
Ist das jetzt das von meinem System Python 3.13 oder von dem Interpreter, was der installiert hat, den 3.14?
Das ist das PIP in der VNV.
Okay, das wird ja mein Rahmen hier dann sein.
Hi, VNV, CFG, 3.14.
Okay, ja, passt, passt.
Okay, heißt im Endeffekt, ich kann jetzt...
Okay, und wie
runne ich jetzt was?
Was ich mit
Pip installiert hab?
Oder sag ich dir einfach UV-Run?
Aha. Okay, ich...
So langsam, aber sicher komm ich,
glaub ich, dahinter.
Okay, wie haben wir das gestern
gemacht? UV-Run?
Ich hab's nämlich schon wieder vergessen.
Hab ich jetzt hier...
Ich hab schon wieder vergessen, wie wir das gestern gemacht haben.
Hier, Standalone.
One File war das, gell?
Error, need file name.
Argument with Python module.
Package director or main program.
Hm.
Heißt im Endeffekt...
Ich kann das gar nicht benutzen,
so wie UV das macht.
Weil wenn ich jetzt...
Oder kann ich Init?
Kann ich dem Init übergeben?
Dass ich dem jetzt sagen kann,
App, nee, Source,
App,
Init.
Nee, oder?
Main Pi habe ich nicht. Gibt's nicht.
Gibt's nicht.
Source Main Pi, oder?
Ne, gibt's nicht.
Standalone Mode on Linux requires Patch 11 to be installed.
Okay.
Pseudo-Abt-Install-Patch-11.
To compile a package, specify its directory, but not the init.
Source.
Can find main module in source.
App.
Geil.
Moment.
Brauch ich jetzt doch diesen Kram hier?
Brauch ich jetzt nicht doch das?
Ne.
Äh, okay.
Can't find main module.
Muss die Datei so heißen, oder was?
Die Datei muss vielleicht
Minus Minus Main heißen
Doch
Aber das ist
Das sagt
also das ist das in it ob es direkt also das in es sollte ich dann nicht anlegen oder wie
er hat die spezifische rechte über not in it
main für bayerisch okay das heißt wir sind wir benennen das jetzt hier um
über nennen das jetzt hier oben in main
Rename
Main
Da gibt es ein Issue zu.
Pog.
Oh ne, mein Rahmen ist wieder fast voll.
Shit.
Ah, jetzt checkt das.
Die sollten Support für UV haben.
Tja.
Anscheinend nicht.
Oder muss ich da irgendwas Spezielles jetzt...
Ach, minus minus project muss ich vielleicht angeben.
Dann checkt das, oder wie?
Schauen wir mal.
Wir müssen uns übrigens cc-cache installieren.
Sonst wird das abartig lange dauern.
ab install cc cache
so app app punkt bin minus es starting on port das wird jetzt nicht richtig funktionieren
Curl.
Localhost 8080.
Äh.
Moment, Moment.
Moment.
Das ist, das ist, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Das ist Fail.
Der liest das hier weiterhin on the fly.
Wenn,
ich wette mit dir, wenn ich das hier jetzt umbenenne,
oder wenn ich das einfach nur eins hochschiebe,
dann geht's nicht mehr.
Siehste?
Der embeddet das nämlich nicht.
Das wäre auch viel zu einfach.
Das ist Zufall,
dass das jetzt noch da liegt.
Okay.
Das ist jetzt die Frage, wie embedde ich das?
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz interessant jetzt.
Weil,
du brauchst für
include data files
Ah ja!
Include files.
Include data files.
Ah ja, to copy some or all files in a directory you use,
where you get to specify shell patterns for the files.
Und wie rufe ich das dann auf im Code?
Oder checkt er das dann einfach?
Ja, File plus Path gibt es ja nicht.
Im Temp-Dir?
Achso!
Der entpackt das beim Starten, oder was?
Weil normalerweise
legt er keine Temp-Files an.
Wenn ich das jetzt starte,
der hat hier keine
irgendwie Temp-Files.
Gibt's nix.
Local.
Oder
Cache.
oder so.
Ach, oder doch?
Ne, ne, cc cache,
module cache, das ist was anderes.
Ja, das denke ich nämlich auch,
dass das mit dem String am einfachsten wäre.
Das, das, das denke ich auch.
Okay, ähm,
String to pi,
ähm,
warte mal, da gibt's bestimmt, da gibt's bestimmt
Tools für, die das machen.
Dass man dann sagen kann, sowas wie,
ich zeig mal, was ich prinzipiell, was ich vorhab,
dass man dann sowas hier sagen kann.
Cat Index HTML
Dass man hier sagen kann, Cat Index HTML
äh
through PyString oder so.
Und dann
kann man das includen, was da rauskommt.
Ja.
Das
probieren wir mal.
Ähm.
String to Python
Bash String to Python String
Ne, okay wir fragen mal chatgpt, chatgpt weiß das bestimmt
I want to format an HTML file into a Python string
Ja, das gibt's doch schon was Fertiges, oder?
Ich meine, eigentlich brauchen wir nur sowas wie
ToString, oder?
Von der
Ich sag nochmal, von der Idee her ist es doch eigentlich
Relativ
Relativ einfach
Wir sagen
Moment, das muss ich jetzt mal ausprobieren
Wie war das? UV?
Mal hier.
UV run Python. So.
Da können wir jetzt sagen, Path,
nee, Import.
Äh, was muss ich importieren?
Path? Path?
Fuck.
Path slip from Path.
Okay.
So, guck mal. Weil das ist ja schon
genauso, wie ich es haben will.
Genau das will ich haben.
Jetzt bräuchten wir einfach die...
Kann man das jetzt noch...
Kann man das jetzt noch printen?
Oh, ne, mein...
Ja!
Perfekt!
Genau das!
Ja!
genau sowas hier.
Ja, das ist ja dann easy. Also das heißt,
im Endeffekt kann man sowas hier machen.
Minus C.
Ah, das geht.
Das wird sie irgendwie sagen.
Import.
Import Path.
Ach so.
Ja, ja. Okay.
Ja.
Aber du willst doch nicht manuelle Strings einfügen.
Na doch.
Das wird dann so als Bild.
Ich mach dann ein Bild-Skript, wo das drin steht.
Und vorher schreibt er das in eine Datei rein.
Das müsste doch eigentlich funktionieren.
Also, from pathlib.
From pathlib import.
Print path.
Read text and code.
So.
Und Print.
Kann man da jetzt sowas hier machen?
Keckel.
Schreibt er das dann raus?
Okay, Keckel.
Also machen wir hier.
HTML Content gleich.
Und das ist eigentlich alles, was wir brauchen.
Genau.
genau. Und dann machen wir jetzt
hier das ganze Soll nach
Source App
und dann
ja, was weiß ich,
eigentlich egal.
HTML oder irgendwie
Content
Pie oder so.
Und jetzt haben wir hier eine Datei
Content Pie und da steht
das String drin. Heißt im Endeffekt,
wir können jetzt hier einfach sagen,
http ane moment wie wie wie wie wie include ich das jetzt html von
checks ok vom app content import hat dem content das mag er nicht warum ist es jetzt
jetzt auf einmal einen String.
Chatgear, warum ist das jetzt ein String? Da steht ein B
davor.
Line too long.
Der fährt jetzt nicht rum.
Warum?
Guck mal, das ist doch Bytes.
Steht doch eindeutig da.
Bytes.
Bytes?
Warum ist das jetzt ein String auf einmal?
Oder ist das...
Oder checkt der Linter das nicht?
Kann ich hier nicht sagen?
Bytes?
Gott, String?
Alter, was laberst du?
Das ist überhaupt kein String.
ok jetzt checkt das okay machen wir das noch einmal mit text
excellent jetzt brauche ich das wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr weil ich ja notations habe okay
Was ich hier mache? Ich versuche gerade HTML in einen Single Binary File Python Script zu embedden.
Das ist wie es gedacht ist.
Protect Data Files.
Your program might be using a Q...
Data File Loaded.
Commercial.
Ja, Moment
Ich hab das nicht
Commercial, ich will das auch nicht als
Commercial
Aber so müsste das doch funktionieren
Jetzt haben wir hier
Den Content, der ausgeliefert wird
Heißt im Endeffekt, wir starten das jetzt mal
UV Run
Ach, das funktioniert jetzt wieder nicht
Ah, fuck
Das geht jetzt nicht, weil das
Init, weil das nicht mehr Init heißt
Okay, wurscht
Wir kompilieren das jetzt noch einmal
Das geht auch viel schneller
Und dann wird es noch einmal gecurlt
Er ist nicht in free drin anscheinend
Auf Compilesor
Hopp hopp
Ist das nicht voll bescheuert?
Das ist Interpretationssache
Mein Go ist der Goat, was das angeht
Chat, wir haben es kaputt gemacht
Wir haben es kaputt gemacht, es geht nicht mehr
Es ist broken
Ich weiß nicht, was ich kaputt gemacht habe, aber ich habe es kaputt gemacht
Es lässt sich
Witzig, aber, ach so, ah, Moment
Das ist, weil ich den Kram jetzt wieder gelöscht hab hier
Aber Python Apps zu distributen
Ist halt richtig eklig, ne
Weil, selbst wenn du ein Skript hast
Wie willst du gescheit ein Skript
Gerade ein Skript
Also gerade so kleine Tools
Das kannst du halt nicht gescheit distributen
Da muss dir irgendwie
Einer den Source Code klonen
Irgendwie Requirements
TXT ausführen und Geschiss
sich seine Kiste versauen.
Genau, das ist, also im Prinzip ist das
Einzige, was du machen kannst, ist einen Container bauen
und da
deine Anwendung drin laufen lassen. Aber für irgendwelche
CLI-Tools, die du überall brauchst,
mit
VNV geht. Soll das funktionieren?
Da musst du halt
dein VNV einchecken. Einer muss sich auschecken.
Da braucht er zumindest mal Python installiert.
Er braucht zumindest mal ein Tool für VNV.
Wobei VNV ist mittlerweile dabei.
Ja.
Docker existiert,
dass du solche Sachen distributen kannst
mit allen Abhängigkeiten drinnen,
um halt eine Anwendung zum Laufen
zu bringen. Aber ein Docker
für ein CLI-Tool ist jetzt...
Ist alles so geil.
Da musst du immer einen Docker-Run machen davor.
Der Sinn von einem CLI-Tool
ist, dass du es einfach ausfüllen kannst.
Und ich meine, es geht ja tatsächlich ganz gut.
Thomas, Fonst, das hat funktioniert mit dem Embedden.
Das ist meine Webseite.
Richtig nice.
Excellent.
Das ist natürlich gegen Lib C compiled.
Das müsste ich jetzt noch gegen die ältere Lib C.
Das haben wir gestern ja gemacht.
Das müssen wir jetzt hier nochmal machen.
Sebidev, moin, lange nicht gesehen.
Auch wieder am Start.
Excellent.
Aber das gefällt mir.
Das gefällt mir richtig gut.
Dass man das so embedden kann.
Was nämlich im Endeffekt heißt,
was wir jetzt machen müssen ist,
Print
das da.
Da.
Wir gehen jetzt hier in unseren
Wir gehen jetzt hier in unser
Bild.sh
dieses ganze Go-Gedöns
schmeißen wir weg.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Wir gehen jetzt nach .app.
Dann machen wir uv run python
bla bla bla bla bla.
Dann machen wir das da.
Und schon.
Wir können auch gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Jetzt schreiben wir nicht blub blub blub rein.
Sondern jetzt schreiben wir in unser HTML
Omega 0 rein.
Omega 0 W.
sagen jetzt
Bild.sh
und es funzt.
Ja, Go ist
absolut goated, was
Self-Contained und Portability
angeht.
Besser als Go
wird es nicht mehr werden.
Und jetzt haben wir unser Bein.
Vielleicht kann man dem Kram auch noch sagen, wo er das Ganze hinschmeißen soll.
App.bin.
Das funktioniert noch.
Also mal App.bin.
Jetzt kommen wir mal.
Minus S.
Hat er jetzt.
Curl.
Ja, Omega-Lol steht jetzt drin.
Okay, das gefällt mir.
Das ist nice.
Jetzt haben wir unser Command-Line-Tool.
Und jetzt ist die Frage noch, irgendjemand hat doch vorhin was gepostet, dass die auch UV unterstützen.
Dass die Pi oder Project-Tommel unterstützen.
Muss ich da minus minus Project angeben oder was?
UvBuild not installed in this environment.
Äh.
Was will er von mir?
Was meinst du mit alles im Binary?
Es gibt kein Projekt, das neu ist.
Okay, also was? Kein Projekt?
Du kannst die Projektoption nicht nutzen.
Checken tue ich selber immer noch nicht, was man jetzt machen muss.
Damit der UV als Basis für das Bild benutzt.
Main Entry Point.
Ah.
Main Entry Point
Brauch ich sowas vielleicht
Ne, No Such Option
Main Entry Point
Also wie funzt das jetzt
Ja, ja, ist alles dabei
Es ist alles dabei in dem Binary
Ja, und was, wie jetzt?
Ich check, was muss man denn jetzt machen?
And it works.
Ja, ich will mir jetzt auch gleich nochmal ein Docker-File bauen,
wo man dann nochmal schauen kann, dass das jetzt auch alles funktioniert am Stück.
And it works.
Geil.
Okay.
Das ist ja schön, dass it, it works.
Alter Browser.
Ich hab ein Problem, ich brauch unbedingt
Ey, ohne Scheiß, ich brauch unbedingt
Mehr RAM
Da drehst du voll am Rad hier
Guckt euch das an
Mein ganzer Memory ist voll
Ich brauch noch was
Geizhals
Hardware
Speicher
Hatten die nicht hier irgendwie Speicher?
RAM
Ist es wieder billiger geworden?
Na ja, sag mal, Chad, was meinst du?
Ich habe 8 Gig da aktuell drin.
Wenn ich mir das hier so angucke, den RAM-Verbrauch,
da habe ich so ein bisschen meine Zweifel,
ob 16 Gig wirklich reichen.
Also müsste ich mir wahrscheinlich noch mal 16 Gig kaufen,
dass ich auf 24 komme. Das sollte dann
reichen.
Okay. DDR5
SO-Dim.
Das macht es halt nochmal extra teuer.
Okay.
Alter, die Preise,
Mann.
kompatibel zu cento s7 ja ja sowas hier das geht doch was doch okay dass das
kann man sich doch ist halt immer noch teuer als fuck aber okay so was so was
ist doch okay so ein ding hol ab alter was preis vor allem das sind dann
irgendwelche komischen Anbieter,
wo man
nicht weiß,
wer das so genau ist.
219.
S-Trade
24.
Okay.
Gibt es hier Bewertungen oder sowas?
Just launched
Ähm
Ich
Bin mir nicht so sicher
Ob ich da truste, Leute
Würdet ihr da trusten?
Dass das ankommt?
Keine Ahnung
Keine Bewertung irgendwie
Und just launched
Ich weiß nicht
200 Euro Gun, ja
Okay, minus minus
Project muss man jetzt tatsächlich schreiben
Minus minus Project
Und brauche ich denn überhaupt was anzugeben?
UV-Bild not installed
Okay
Ich check nicht, was die da von mir wollen.
Jetzt ist es okay.
Das ist Chat-GPT.
Chat-GPT.
Moment, das muss man machen?
Max, meine bessere Hälfte wurde gescampt.
Willst du wissen, wie?
Ja, erzähl.
Minus Minus Project
Output Files
Und dann
Main Pi
Ja, das hat doch vorher schon funktioniert
Okay, dann ist das gar nicht das Problem
Was ich hab, sondern
Dann ist das alles okay
Mein Problem ist, dass
UV
Auf, brech ab.
Okay, will nicht.
Hat keinen Bock, ich muss warten, bis es kompiliert hat.
Abbruch ist keine Option hier.
So, aber UV-Run-App funktioniert nicht, weil mein Entry-Point nicht funzt.
Cannot import.
Name from App.
Main from App.
Ja, weil das hier nicht Init heißt, oder?
wenn ich das, ich wette mit euch, wenn ich das hier wieder
rename auf init,
oh, ich check dieses Handling,
dann wird's wieder, dann funzt's wieder.
Muss man das vielleicht in diesen
PyProject reinschreiben?
Project Script System.
Okay, das ist mir zu hoch.
Weil wenn ich's jetzt
kompilieren will, dann mag er
wieder nicht.
Minus, minus
project.
Not installed.
Ich mache jetzt einfach mal blind das, was
ChatGPT empfiehlt. Bam.
Geht nicht.
Das
not provide minus minus main
minus
main entry
point
äh
main gleich
äh, Main?
Ja, natürlich nicht.
Okay, was muss ich da jetzt?
Ja, was will es denn da jetzt von mir?
Kacke.
Okay, das funzt schon mal nicht.
wie wäre es mit einem fucking example alter
oder muss ich da sowas angeben wie app natürlich main entry point gleich
App.
Okay. Bin ich zu
zu PP dafür, wie das funktioniert.
30 Milliarden.
Main Entry Point.
Entry
Point.
Package
Main as the Entry Point.
Was?
Bin gleich Module?
What the fuck, Alter?
Das ist wirklich super krass.
Six Head, ey.
Okay, sowas muss man da angeben
What?
Und Project kann man weglassen dann, oder was?
Ey
Ich hab legit keine Ahnung, wie es funktionieren soll
Vor allem, was soll mir diese Kackfehler-Meldung denn jetzt sagen?
Hat online...
Okay, jetzt halt mal.
Hat online gekauft und der Verkäufer hat dann einfach auf Rechnung in seinem anderen Shop bestellt.
Ware kommt ein paar Monate später die Mahnung.
Hä? Moment, das habe ich jetzt nicht gecheckt.
hat online gekauft und der Verkäufer hat dann einfach auf Rechnung in einem anderen Shop bestellt.
Warte, kommt ein paar Minuten später.
Moment.
Ihr habt online bestellt und der Verkäufer hat quasi in eurem Namen in einem anderen Online-Shop auf Rechnung bestellt.
Das ist ja auch ein geiler Scam, ey.
Reselling ohne zu bezahlen.
Das ist ja auch mal ein geiler Scam
UV, run
Nein
Okay, ich erkenne, das ist wirklich äußerst feifett, das da zum Laufen zu bekommen.
Aber wir können das ganz einfach austricksen.
Also, aus irgendwelchen Gründen ist das so.
Also das check ich hier nicht mit dem Main Entry Point.
Wir tricksen das jetzt aus.
Ach so.
Also kann ich hier einfach sagen, main
main gleich
und dann source app
init.py
oder was?
Das wäre auch zu einfach.
Jetzt kann man das weglassen?
To compile a package, specify...
Oh Mann.
Ja, habe ich doch.
Cannot find main module.
Genau das gleiche Problem.
Okay, wir drecksen das jetzt einfach aus.
Wir tricksen das jetzt einfach aus.
Wir haben hier einen Init.
Und dann machen wir jetzt hier einfach einen Main.
Nochmal rein.
Der.
Das checkt.
Und dann aufruft.
Init.
Wie geht denn das jetzt?
Wie kann ich ihn jetzt.
Ihr App
App.
Main.
Bam. Easy.
Geht.
Dann machen wir es halt so.
Wenn er es nicht checkt, ist es okay.
Und das hier kann auch weg.
Dann ruft UV das auf
und der Compiler das andere.
So.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt hier
mein Build-Skript starte, dann
funzt das. Gut.
Dann brauchen wir
jetzt ja nur noch
das Docker-File
für
das Many-Linux von gestern.
Und schon
ratzfatz, naja,
3 Stunden 15,
sollten wir uns
was kompilieren können,
was Standalone laufbar ist
seit Ubuntu 12.04.
Also, dann gehen wir hier mal in das Docker,
wobei, das machen wir von hier.
Gehen wir mal in das Docker-File.
Also, golang-trixi. Ne.
Many Linux
Das da wollen wir.
Also, Docker-File
from
many Linux.
Wir müssen jetzt installieren.
apt
run apt update
run apt install
cc cache und
wie ist das andere? 11 patch, gell?
Hast du schon Mittag
gegessen? Ja.
workdir slash build
ist okay. Das brauchen wir nicht.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Das brauchen wir alles nicht.
Brauchen wir alles? Alles nicht. Das war's.
Den brauchen wir nicht, oder?
Ah, doch. Doch. Wir brauchen dieses
Static. Hier.
Das da.
Äh, nee. Hier.
Include?
Wie hieß das?
Oh, ich hab's vergessen gestern.
Include?
Das hab ich nicht in meiner History.
Fuck. Ich kack, Nubala.
Nee, nicht Patch 11.
Man musste sowas Spezielles installieren.
Weiß nicht mehr.
So, also jetzt haben wir hier erstmal ein Docker.
Jetzt haben wir hier ein Docker-Image.
Wir bauen das gerade mal testweise.
Also, Docker,
Docker, Build, minus Tag,
TMP.
Accessibility ist
deprecated.
Install Buildkit. Warum?
Habe ich
das nicht?
Habe ich kein Buildkit?
Ich dachte, das ist Standard mittlerweile.
Nehmen wir das.
Leute, ich brauche mehr RAM.
Das Geswoppe macht mich fertig.
So drei Jahre sollte der jetzt eigentlich nicht brauchen, um Buildkit zu installieren, oder?
Okay.
Falscher Mirror.
Oh, what?
404.
Oh, ich müsste, glaube ich, upgraden, damit das richtig funktioniert.
Ähm.
Ne, das war ich jetzt nicht.
ok bild mal einfach so dann haben wir das alte ist auch egal so docker bild
temp ich habe mich vertippt in meinem docker file run wo ist das problem
ah jam update jam install das ist ja red hat das ist ja red hat image herr wohner
dass das mit up install net funktioniert wie gesagt ich habe schon
Ich hab heute Nudel, Pilze, Rahmsoße und vegane Hackfleisch.
Gefuttert.
Not tolerating missing names on install.
Was?
Ah ne.
Patch 11, nicht 11 Patch.
Was?
Alter, was willst du von mir? Warum geht das nicht?
Achso, weil ich minus Y vergessen habe.
Okay, jetzt baut er mir einen Docker-Container.
So, und jetzt mal gucken, ob ich das noch auf die Reihe kriege, wie ich das gestern gemacht habe.
Also, Docker run.
Docker run.
Ja, von gestern.
Ja, pwd, das ist okay.
Temp.
Wie habe ich das gestern gemacht mit dem Bilden?
Wir müssten nach Opt
Python cp
Das hier, 341
Das da
Bin
Pip
War das so?
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher
Instant
Moment, brauche ich jetzt überhaupt UV?
Ja, ja, ne?
Install UV.
Okay, das ist, okay, das, das, das müssen wir auf jeden Fall dann als erstes machen.
Jetzt machen wir noch ein Docker-File.
Docker-File.
Run.
Kommt da oben hin.
So, Docker-File, also
UV, dann mussten
wir jetzt nach
dann wechseln wir da jetzt rein
und da müssen wir jetzt sagen
App
UV
Wie war das?
UV, Run
Standalone
Will nicht, warum?
No such file or directory
Ach, fail to spawn.
Ähm.
Moment.
Wie installiert man denn?
Wie installiert man denn jetzt die
Dependencies
mit UV?
Pyre Project
Build System
und
hier Ridge Hammer.
Gibt es sowas wie
UV Update oder sowas?
Ne.
V-Install?
In it?
Add? Remove? Sync?
Ne.
Ja.
Äh.
Wie macht man das jetzt?
UV-Sync ist das?
Ne.
er muss ja der soll den kram installieren uv install dependencies
clown repo managing dependencies ja so schlau bin ich
remove changing dependencies project dependencies dependencies ja es ist ja
schön und gut
ach moment oder hat er das jetzt gemacht
Du hast recht
Du hast recht, ich hab die über pip installiert
Ich muss, ich muss Dings hier machen
Def
Hier, das muss ich machen
UV add
Def
Was?
Äh.
Oh, fuck.
Habe ich es jetzt kaputt gemacht, weil ich hier mit einem Docker-Container drin rumgewurschtelt habe?
Okay.
Schlechte Idee.
Okay, schlechte Idee.
Okay, da muss ich mir noch was anderes überlegen.
Das muss ich vorher in den Container kopieren.
Sonst macht es keinen Sinn.
Wartet mal.
Das macht keinen Sinn.
Wir müssen...
Ja.
CH own.
Max, Max.
Zack.
Operation not permitted.
Ja, ja.
Damn.
Okay, gut.
Ich...
Das ist voll Blindflug, ne?
Ich habe überhaupt keinen Plan.
Ignoring existing
virtual environment linked to non-existing
Python-Interpreter. Ja, gut.
Wollt mir recht sein.
UV-List.
Oder UV-Python-List.
Okay, gut.
Also.
Also, hat er das denn jetzt auch gecheckt mit der Version, dass es 3.14 sein soll?
Ja.
Okay.
Das heißt, wenn ich das Docker-File baue dafür, dann muss ich Copy alles nach Build machen.
Wobei eigentlich nicht alles.
Ja doch.
Mehr oder weniger alles.
Das gefällt mir auch noch nicht.
Aber immerhin.
Hier, Temp bilden.
Nee, nicht Run.
Build.
Ja, der kopiert jetzt halt einiges, ne?
So, und jetzt kann ich hier
Add Dependency.
Warte mal, ich kann abbrechen.
Ah, ne, war schon.
Und was macht UV-Sync jetzt?
Ja, es sind 127 MB.
Komm da jetzt halt dabei.
Das muss ich anderweitig noch gucken.
Ich glaube, ich brauche da nochmal ein Unterverzeichnis.
Naja, schauen wir mal.
So, jetzt macht er sein ganzes Update-Gedöns.
Ah, ich bin dumm.
Das muss ich in Zukunft
auch nochmal umdrehen.
Das Copy muss natürlich
hier nachkommen.
Sonst macht er ja jedes Mal diesen ganzen Krempe.
Das wäre ja kompletter Schwachsinn.
So, jetzt kopiert er sich diesen Kram hier rein.
Okay, hat funktioniert.
So, jetzt hat er sich diesen Kram hier reinkopiert.
Das macht er nochmal, aber das nächste Mal geht es schneller.
Jetzt hat er sich den ganzen Kram hier reinkopiert.
Und jetzt kann ich das nochmal ausprobieren.
Mit dem...
Ob er das jetzt auch nachinstalliert.
Leute, hier ist übertrieben warm drin.
29 Grad oder sowas.
Ich sehe es nicht richtig hier auf dem Thermometer.
Es ist brutal warm.
Also, wie sieht es bei euch aus?
Alle dead?
Chat, seid ihr am einpennen, oder?
Kann ich aber auch verstehen.
Sind schon dreieinhalb Stunden hier am Start.
Okay, jetzt macht er das Copy.
So, run.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Wie ging das jetzt weiter?
Jetzt müssen wir UV.
ran ran wird doch hier sind wir jetzt uv sync kann ich jetzt mal machen auch
okay no project top tommel found wie an die ist da die project tommel ok ab
Alles gut.
Project Tommel.
UV-Sync.
Ah, jetzt installiert er den Kram.
Verstehe.
Jetzt habe ich es gecheckt.
Okay.
Jetzt hat er diesen ganzen Krempel installiert.
Und jetzt kann ich auch sagen...
One File.
UV Run.
Ah, genau diesen Krempel musste ich vorher noch machen.
Das habe ich gesucht.
Machen wir jetzt hier noch Wim.
So, übrigens Copy ist Blödsinn.
Wir kopieren App dahin.
Nicht alles.
Alles brauchen wir nicht.
Das müssen wir auch vorher machen.
So, nachdem wir das dahin kopiert haben,
müssen wir dann sagen,
dass da Run Standalone auf App.
So, ja gut.
Dann machen wir vorher noch das da.
Hier drinnen, um das zu testen.
Fail to spawn.
Cost by? No such file or directory.
Ah, weil App.
Aber das sieht dann später nicht so aus.
Muss nach App.
Und dann funzt es.
Sehr gut.
Okay, gut.
Ja, denn?
Dann wollen wir mal
haben wir einen Docker-Container.
Docker-Build.
Nennen wir das mal
PyCLI-Champ
oder so.
Also das heißt, in unserem
Build-Script machen wir
Nicht das da, sondern...
Achso, diesen Shit müssen wir auch noch irgendwie machen.
Das könnte man als Set-Sauerszenario machen.
Ja, Moment. Das...
Das kann ich ja schon
noch im Dock...
Das kann ich ja schon noch im Docker-File machen.
Hier.
Run.
UV-Run.
Ja.
Ja, ja.
Kann ich hier noch machen.
Also, Docker Build.
Das da kann weg.
Wir gehen auch nicht nach App.
Wir sagen, Docker Build PyChamp CLI.
Danach sagen wir,
Docker Run.
Ich hoffe, das
kommt jetzt irgendwie hin.
Danach sagen wir, Docker Run.
Wir brauchen kein Verzeichnis.
Mount.
Oder brauchen wir...
Doch, wir mounten uns mal ein Verzeichnis.
Nicht verkehrt.
So.
Docker run.
Das machen wir vorher.
So, jetzt machen wir da im Prinzip
eigentlich nur noch das hier drin.
In dem Docker-Container.
Vorher müssen wir noch nach
slash
build oder so wechseln.
So, mal gucken, ob das jetzt Sinn ergibt, was ich hier gebaut habe.
In App löschen wir mal dieses ganze Gedöns.
Auch nochmal aus, nochmal aus, stopp, stopp, stopp, nochmal bilden.
Jetzt nehme ich viel schneller.
Kunst?
Guck mal.
Guck mal, es funktioniert, oder?
Oh, nee.
Fail to spawn.
Warum?
Was habe ich falsch gemacht, Leute?
Was habe ich falsch gemacht?
Was, was ist falsch?
Achso, Moment.
Temp? Ne.
Highchamp CLI.
Aha.
Okay, Fonz. Nice.
Und dann machen wir hier jetzt noch
Hier drinnen gibt es jetzt noch einen Ordner
Ja ja, okay, passt
Aber das ist das für uns
Ich breche nochmal kurz ab
Nochmal das Build-Skript raushauen
Wir machen uns jetzt hier noch einen Ordner
mkdir build
Oder ne, rm, falls er da ist, löschen wir den
rm, rm-rf build
So, dann bilden wir das Ganze hier.
Und wenn das fertig ist, kopieren wir...
...slash data...
...ne, äh...
...app.bin heißt der ganze Krempel dann, glaube ich.
Nach slash...
...data slash build.
mkdir build.
Jetzt erstmal gelöscht, falls es da ist.
So, und dann sollten wir das
Binary
in diesem Verzeichnis haben.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Mockass, mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Wir haben jetzt wirklich nicht viel
CLI geübt,
ja, aber
das Gesamtkonstrukt
ist nice.
Ja, SebiDev, bist du noch am Start?
Jetzt kannst du gleich sehen, jetzt kriegen wir einen Binary, was rückwirkend auf Ubuntu 12.04 läuft.
Okay, das wird jetzt initial ganz schön lahm sein.
Ne, so viele Files haben wir ja gar nicht.
Es geht sogar halbwegs.
Geht sogar.
So.
Ich hoffe, ich habe das jetzt richtig gemacht.
Okay, haben wir jetzt hier ein Bild
Bild
Und da liegt die App drin
Wie groß ist sie?
7 MB
7,1 MB
App bin
Bam
Minus S
Fuck
Already in use
Achso, ja, wegen SSH
Okay, Leute
Es ist eine dumme Idee gewesen
Den Port
H zu coden
Dumme Idee, gebe ich zu
Wenn der Port hardcoded ist
Geht das natürlich nicht
Okay, dann, Chat, sind wir noch auf Python
Wie?
Okay
Hier, Default
Kann man auch machen, ne?
Default 8080
konnte man irgendwie sagen typ oder so
hat okay keine ahnung wie sagt man hier typ
wie sagt man das hier at argument
Type
Ne
Type String Any
Kann man da nicht sagen
Type Number
Oder ist das JavaScript
Oder Type Int
Sagt man das so
Gibt es sowas wie
U Short
Ne sowas gibt es in Python nicht oder
Aber Int
Int muss man dann wahrscheinlich sagen
Probieren wir das mal aus hier
UV Run App
Minus S
Fail to Spawn App. Ja, weil ich im falschen Verzeichnis bin.
Expected
Argument. Warum
Expected das ein Argument, wenn ich
die Fault hab?
Aber wahrscheinlich, weil ich wieder
dieses komische Action
Surf. Wie war das?
Fuck, hab ich vergessen. Surf
Load.
Irgendwie Load, oder?
Ne. Save.
Save.
Action.
Gleich.
Store true.
WTF. Was auch immer.
Also, so, jetzt.
Check das jetzt vielleicht.
Äh.
What?
Got an unexpected keyword argument type.
Okay.
Habe ich das vorher nicht irgendwie so gesehen hier mit Type?
Naja.
Okay.
Also wenn ich es nicht angebe, dann nimmt er den Default-Port.
Gut.
Jetzt mal, okay.
Mal eine andere Frage.
Wie kann ich denn jetzt auf den Port hier zugreifen?
Arx?
Rind.
Arx.
S.
Oder Surf.
Und dann?
Dann 1 oder sowas.
Dann sowas wie hier 0 oder so vielleicht.
Ja, aber ich will ja auf den Inhalt zugreifen.
Weil, true, ja klar.
Ich will ja hier, was da drin steht.
80, 80.
Nee.
Direkt Arx-Surf geht nicht.
Da kommt True raus.
Vielleicht ist das Arx...
Vielleicht ist der wirklich so.
Nee.
Okay.
Wenn ich jetzt was angebe, geht's dann?
Unrecognized Argument...
Hä?
Ach, das macht dann ein Fleck draus.
Okay.
Okay, gut.
Das Ding ist jetzt nur...
Das Ding ist jetzt nur, wenn ich es nur so angebe...
Expected one argument.
Dann bringt mir doch das Default gar nichts.
Okay.
Ich frag mal, dafür ist wahrscheinlich Chat-GPD gar nicht so schlecht.
Ohne Minus S?
Ach einfach, kein Minus S.
Ja, das ist ja auch keine Option.
Ja, ich brauch Subcommands auf jeden Fall.
Ich brauch auf jeden Fall Subcommands, sonst ist es unsinnig.
Wir machen hier das...
Ist die voll weg?
Ne, das ist unsinnig.
Ja, da muss man hier 1, 2, 3, 4, ja, okay.
Das müssen wir anders machen.
Ich glaube, es wird nochmal Zeit für noch einen Stream.
Nicht unbedingt direkt morgen,
aber vielleicht die nächsten Tage,
wo wir uns mal wirklich dann mit CLI-Frameworks und so beschäftigen.
Ich glaube, das ist ganz sinnig.
So, ich habe übrigens noch eine Stunde Zeit.
Also wir haben noch mehr als genug Zeit, weiterzubasteln.
Du kannst P für Port hinzufügen.
Ich lasse es jetzt erstmal so.
Geht ja nur darum, dass ich meinen Port-Konflikt hier...
Oh.
If arg serve.
Und das heißt, hier kann ich jetzt...
Oh, wie ging das bei Python?
Ähm, String Interpolation.
So?
Oder F, F, F muss man machen, oder?
Genau.
Ja, ja.
Siehst du mal.
Hab schon gecheckt, ganz ohne Chat.
Eisner ist schon eine recht hübsche Sprache, muss man sagen.
Axe.
Port.
Dann kriegt...
So, das hier meckert bestimmt, dass es kein String ist, sondern ein Int braucht, oder?
Genau.
So, da muss ich jetzt sagen, macht es zu einem Int.
Und dann checkt das.
Sehr gut.
Exzellent, würde ich dazu sagen.
Das ist exzellent.
Yeah.
Sehr schön.
Dann machen wir das doch jetzt noch einmal.
Und zwar, wir haben doch jetzt unser schönes Build-Skript.
Unser schönes Build-Skript.
Build-Skript.
Bam.
Ah.
Brauchen wir noch eine andere Sache, glaube ich.
Ach ne, macht er ja nur da drinnen.
Dann ist es nicht so wild.
Äh, was macht er da?
Was ist das hier?
Achso, das ist Wasser.
Guck mal.
Wozu brauchen wir jetzt diesen übermäßig intelligenten Server, um eine Test-HTML-Seite zu surfen?
Aber das Geile ist, und das gefällt mir richtig gut, das Ding surft jetzt sogar unter Ubuntu 12.04.
Oder Sebi, was wolltest du nochmal sehen?
CentOS 7, glaube ich, gell?
Okay, ob CentOS 7 geht, weiß ich nicht
Aber Ubuntu 12.04 geht
Also sollte CentOS 7 eigentlich auch gehen
Okay, so, hier
Bild
App.bin
Zack
Minus
Oh man, ich kann nicht tippen
Minus S1234
Zack
Satigon Port
Localhost Port
Zack
Omega Lull. Webseite wird gesurft.
Ja, gut. Jetzt wird abgebrochen.
Weiß nicht, wie man das unterbinden kann.
So, und jetzt
kommt der Moment der Wahrheit.
Also, erst einmal
Ubuntu. Ubuntu 12.04.
Data.
Äh,
Bild.
App.bin
1234.
Kunst.
Ubuntu 12.04 läuft.
Next.
CentOS 7.
Chatke.
Daumen hoch, Daumen runter.
Geht es auch unter CentOS 7?
Was meint ihr?
Postchamp.
Geht.
Ich glaube auch, dass es geht.
App.bin.
1, 2, 3, 4.
Tag.
Jetzt muss ich natürlich noch beweisen, dass es auch wirklich funktioniert.
Oh.
Leute, man kann unter CentOS 7 nichts mehr installieren.
Okay, das ist unpraktisch.
Dann müssen wir jetzt...
Oh, ich hab eine Idee.
Pass auf. Six at a time.
Tell not. Ist tell not drauf?
Nee.
Moment.
Bash TCP.
Es gab doch die Möglichkeit mit Bash TCP...
Ja, genau.
Es ist doch hier, Bash.
Dev TCP.
Ah ne, Connection Refused.
Okay, da muss ich doch mal den Container neu starten.
Run, minus Port, 1234, 1234.
Data, App, ne, Bild.
App, S, 1234.
Jetzt kommt der Moment der Wahrheit.
Curl, Local Host, 1, 2, 3, 4.
Es kommt nicht auf den Container an.
Warum nicht?
Chat, was habe ich
ver...
verpp-gart?
Was habe ich verkehrt gemacht?
Wahrscheinlich wegen Local Host, oder?
Muss ich da sowas machen?
Geht, geht.
Geht da sowas?
Ne.
Äh.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Ich hab, ich hab keinen Plastenschimmer.
Ah, das Problem ist,
wahrscheinlich, warte mal,
Nicht, weil ich nicht...
Ich muss Dings hier machen.
Oder? Kann das sein, dass ich mal explizit
sagen muss?
Ey, oder?
Dass man irgendwie so sagen muss?
Docker PS?
data bild app minus 1 1 2 3 4 hey okay ich bin zu dumm keine ahnung oder oder
jetzt auch so von so zu so
Okay, ich bin echt zu pepega für Port Forwarding gerade.
Lauscht die Applikation auf 000?
Nee, deswegen wollte ich das ja eben angeben.
Macht sie nicht.
Die lauscht nur auf Localhost.
Kann man das dann überhaupt weiter neiden?
Das geht dann wahrscheinlich gar nicht.
Okay, wir müssen es nochmal anpassen.
Und zwar auf 0.0.0 lauschen wir jetzt.
Okay.
Also nochmal.
Bild.
Warum kopiert der eigentlich so lang?
Das ist doch jetzt nicht so, als wäre das
sonderlich groß. Ich meine, das sind ein paar Bytes.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Ein paar Bytes sind das.
Ja, dann lassen wir es nochmal kompilieren.
Auch gut.
Aber jetzt sollte es funktionieren.
0, 0, 0, 0.
1, 2, 3, 4 lauscht gleich.
Der Compile-Prozess dauert
lange. Das hatten wir gestern auch schon.
Gestern war es noch viel schlimmer.
Gestern haben wir noch Rich mitkompiliert.
Was heißt, wir hatten noch 328 Dateien, die kompiliert werden müssen.
Das hat bestimmt drei Minuten gedauert.
haben wir es gleich auf meine kompensoren centos cd data bild app
Minus S, 1, 3, 4.
So.
Cool.
Bam! Da ist es.
Da ist Funst, Leute.
Aus Surft
von CentOS 7.
Fuck, oder?
Wir haben eine Python-App,
die mit
3,14
Krempel läuft.
Aktuelle Libraries
und alles und lauffähig unter CentOS 7.
Ist das nicht nice?
Übrigens, Chat,
unter Alpine Linux ist es nicht lauffähig.
Wie groß ist die jetzt?
Ich glaube 7 MB.
7 MB war das, glaube ich.
Gucken wir mal.
7 MB.
Unter Alpine Linux läuft das Ganze nicht.
Das liegt daran,
ich kann es euch zeigen
weil die immer
also die Linken, also das ist egal
und das ist egal
die einzige Dependency
die das Ganze hat ist
ein Linux
mit GLIB C
und nachdem wir das Ganze
gebaut haben
auf irgendeinem uralt
Red Hat Linux
geht das. Also GLIB-C
ist dynamisch gelinkt.
Das heißt, wir verwenden immer die,
die auf dem System installiert ist.
Aber GLIB-C ist selbst
so gebaut, die ist
quasi
vorwärtskompatibel
oder weiß nicht, wie man das gescheit nennen soll.
Also du kannst,
wenn du eine Anwendung
kompiliert hast auf einem ur-ur-uralt Linux,
läuft die auf jedem
Linux mit einer neueren
GLIPC als damals.
Also die GLIPC von damals und alle
neueren immer.
Was nicht geht rückwärts.
Deswegen ist das auch so
Painstamp solche Anwendungen zu bauen,
weil bei Go, Go ist
Goated, Single, Single Executables
und Portability mäßig.
Bei Go ist es egal. Bei Go
kannst du die Anwendungen kompilieren bei dir
lokal auf deiner Entwicklerkiste
mit dem neuesten Arch Linux und die ist
lauffähig auf
allen Linux-Kisten,
die, ich glaube, mittlerweile
mindestens ein Kernel 3.2 haben.
Also auch seit den letzten 14 Jahren.
Also Go ist beste.
Das hier ist, denke ich, auch ganz
okay. Auf
allen GLEP-C-basierten Linux-Systemen
seit
2014.
Oder seit, ne, nicht seit
Seit 2012 auch schon.
Also ich denke, das ist zwar nicht ganz so gut wie Go, aber das ist schon die nächste Stufe.
Also die nächste Stufe ist schon echt in Ordnung.
Was ich jetzt halt allerdings nicht weiß ist, wie gut das funktioniert, wenn die Apps umfangreicher werden.
Also ich habe gestern mal eine App mit NumPy versucht zu Compile so an.
Das hat auch funktioniert.
und das hat native native module gehabt
np noch hier namen bei ja wir können das super mit peyton
peyton kannst du kannst du klicken wir können das jetzt tatsächlich noch mal
probieren import namen ps np meist ring print so das machen wir jetzt noch mal
Wir machen jetzt, wir hauen jetzt Nampai dabei.
Das kommt jetzt hier bei Main, kommt jetzt einfach die Ausgabe.
So, Nampai ist nicht installiert.
Ist der denn jetzt so schlau und checkt, dass das ein UV-Projekt ist?
Wenn ich Nampai installiert habe?
Oder wie macht das, wie macht das...
Add NumPy to Project Requirements
Hat er das jetzt gecheckt?
PyProject
NumPy
Hat er kapiert
Oh, wir müssen eine ältere NumPy Version nehmen
Fällt mir gerade auf, weil
NumPy braucht
GCC größer 10.3
Und das haben wir nicht
Pass auf, werden wir gleich sehen
Also wir können das UV nochmal checken, dass das funktioniert.
Ja, UV Run App.
Bam, Funst.
Hier, NumPy-Ausgabe geht auch.
Wenn wir das jetzt allerdings versuchen zu bilden,
dann wird das nicht funktionieren,
weil NumPy einen neueren Compiler braucht,
als bei diesem Ur-Ur-Uralt-Redhead dabei ist.
Glaube ich zumindest.
Welche Version haben wir da gestern verwendet?
Haben wir noch gestern?
2.6 oder so, ne?
Irgendwas.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Namen, Pi.
Ja, das da. 2.6.
2.
Ja, 2.32
brauchen wir.
Äh, Moment.
Chat, warum
funktioniert das jetzt?
Ich bin verwirrt.
Hä?
Wie? What?
Äh, Chat?
Warum geht das jetzt?
Ist das vielleicht
pre-compiled vielleicht?
Okay.
Ich hab nix gesagt.
SS in den Projekt-Requirements.
Die EDE checkt's noch nicht.
Chat, bin ich jetzt total hängen geblieben?
Das ging doch gestern nicht in der neuesten
Nampai-Version.
Oder war das gar nicht Nampai,
was gestern Probleme gemacht hat?
Oder war das was anderes?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich war es nicht.
Das wundert mich, dass das funktioniert.
Okay.
Er soll mir recht sein.
Ne, 10.2 war zu alt.
10.3 ist okay.
Es ist aber nur 10.2, was das heißt.
Also ich keine Ahnung, warum NumPy funktioniert.
Soll mir aber recht sein.
Ist in Ordnung.
Chat, wie sortiert man denn diese Imports richtig?
Zuerst alle ohne Sub-Imports und unten die vom eigenen Projekt, oder wie?
By the way, warum sagt man eigentlich
NumPy, S, N, P
und kann ich einfach NumPy
importen und dann hier sagen
und dann hier sagen
NumPy Array
Das soll jetzt auch funktionieren
Ja, uns
Ist länger, achso
Erst Standardlib, dann Party, dann eigene
Ja, das ist ja alles Standardlibrary
Würdest du diese
Also
Ich glaube, so ist nicht so schön, oder?
Wenn man das so mischen würde, oder?
Das sieht doch kacke aus
So Import
Und dann from Import dazwischen
Also ich denke mal, so ist schon besser
Das brauchen wir übrigens nicht mehr
Hammer doch schon.
Der checkt aber nicht, dass es in den Requirements drin ist.
Muss man das vielleicht reloaden, das Projekt?
Reload?
Hm.
Ne, checkt er nicht.
Kann man das Projekt vielleicht
closen oder so und dann wieder öffnen?
machen wir mal so vielleicht vielleicht checkt checkt die idee dass dann so jetzt
hat er nur app geöffnet ja das ist ja nicht das was ich haben will öffnen
und jetzt hat er gecheckt dass namen peiler drin steht der ist nicht so der
allerschnellste Checker, glaube ich.
Shadows name
content from
outer scope.
Ach so. Ja klar.
Ich kann doch einfach auch sagen
from
app
content
http content, oder?
Kann ich das Ganze hier weglassen?
Bam.
So.
Zack.
Wird nichts mehr importet.
Du glaubst, das mit dem Swap tut ihm nicht so gut?
Das kann schon sein.
Also Leute, ich brauche unbedingt mehr RAM für die Kiste.
Das Ding hier brummt komplett.
Noch eine Idee, was wir einbauen sollen jetzt auf die Schnelle.
Vielleicht, was könnte denn noch ganz spannend sein?
Um jetzt nochmal schnell einzubauen, um zu gucken, ob sich das mit Kompilieren läst.
Also jetzt irgendwie großartige Five-Head-Command-Line-Argumente will ich nicht machen.
Da gucke ich mir lieber das nächste Mal Command-Line-Framework-Sachen an.
Was könnte man da jetzt nochmal auf die Schnelle einbauen, um zu gucken, ob es funktioniert?
Weil wir haben jetzt ein ganz gutes Projektsetup.
Keine Ahnung, ob es irgendwas gibt, um die Performance zu testen.
Ja, weiß nicht.
Was, du könntest Fast-RP mal testen und dann schauen, ob das mit dem Unicorn-Bundle klappt?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, vor was du sprichst.
Fast-RP-Unicorn-Bundle.
Ach, du meinst, ob ich das so hinkriege,
dass das alles auch self-contained ist mit Fast-RP, ja?
Ein Bild mit auf der HTML-Seite anzeigen.
Ja, gut.
Können wir tatsächlich mal...
Das probieren wir mal aus, ob das funktioniert.
Da müssen wir ein Inline-Bild machen.
Da müssen wir inline ein Bild machen.
Und zwar...
Moment.
Pack W.
Das da.
Beste.
Das brauchen wir jetzt.
Copy Image Link.
Hier, warte mal.
Convert Image to...
Kann das Chat-GPT für einen machen?
Convert Image
to
HTML
Image with
Embedded Resource.
Ja doch, als Base64.
Äh, nee, das ist
dumm. Convert
Image to
Resource HTML. Ich weiß nicht,
wie der Kram heißt.
Image to HTML
Generator.
Ich weiß nicht,
wie der Kram heißt.
Da gibt es so
einen...
Hier.
Embed Image HTML.
Nicht SVG. Man kann
das embedden.
Es gibt so ein
Ressource-Dings
dafür.
Boah, wie heißt denn das?
Embedded URL.
Base 64.
Source.
Data URL.
Das suche ich.
Retrieve file from a URL.
Bam.
Das da.
Use piece encode data.
Das brauchen wir.
Genau das.
Das da.
Es ist nicht schön, Leute, hier.
Bam.
So, und jetzt brauchen wir hier, wie
funzt das? HTML-Stills. Image.
Image.
Source.
Hallo?
Und das kann man dann da einfach
so reinkopieren.
Glaube ich.
Ja, ja, das ist gut.
Missing old attribute.
Omega-Ludel.
Lass uns mal ausprobieren,
ob das prinzipiell funktioniert, was ich jetzt hier
gebaut habe.
App, Source,
App,
Index,
Firefox,
Developer Edition,
Index HTML.
Jawohl,
bam, da ist es.
Excellent.
Da können wir doch auch gleich mal
gucken, ob unser automatisches Generieren
funktioniert.
Oh nein.
Guck mal hier.
Chat.
NumPy requires GCC.
Äh.
Chat, ich bin krass verwirrt.
Guck mal, hier
NumPy fail zu bilden
Aber, aber
Aber danach funktioniert es trotzdem
Hä?
Jetzt bin ich, jetzt bin ich komplett verwirrt
Keine Ahnung
Zu low IQ wahrscheinlich
Okay hier
Build, App, das da, bam
Achtung, Local Host, Port
1, 2, 3, 4, ups
Oh, es hat nicht funktioniert
Leute, es hat nicht funktioniert
Unser Build, unser Build ist broken
Warum hat es nicht funktioniert?
Dockerfile.
Das funzt nicht, was wir hier gebaut haben.
Das ist kaputt.
Das Dockerfile
jebaitet uns.
Ich weiß aber nicht, was ich da verkehrt gemacht hab.
Naja, macht nichts. Wir machen das einfach hier.
Zack.
Und jetzt nochmal.
Also es hat noch ein paar, hat noch ein paar, wie soll man sagen, nicht so, nicht so runde Ecken.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen, ich fand es eigentlich erstaunlich gut.
Also nach dem Park, guck mal, das verstehe ich nicht.
Hier kackt NumPy beim Bilden ab.
Aber danach beim Erzeugen des Binarys?
Ach, ich glaube, ich weiß, woran das geht.
Nee, nee, ich weiß, warum das geht.
Das hier ist ja die normale NumPy-Installation.
Über PIP.
Das fehlt.
Aber dieser Compiler, der hat wahrscheinlich NumPy schon included,
weil das so beliebtes Package ist.
Deswegen muss er das nicht neu kompilieren.
Das könnte es doch sein.
Der hat wahrscheinlich einfach die beliebtesten
die beliebtesten Extensions schon
included.
Ja, wahrscheinlich ist es das.
Da gehe ich immer von aus.
Das wird es sein.
Bam.
Hat wieder nicht funktioniert.
Alter, was?
Warum nicht?
Warum schreiben wir nicht einfach direkt in die Content-Pi, sondern konvertieren das vorher?
Ja, weil in Content-Pi das HTML als so komisch...
Aber hier ist doch richtig.
Hier ist doch richtig.
Hä?
Jetzt blick ich schnell mal durch.
Curl?
Ne.
Hä?
Ne, ne, ne. Nicht Browser Cache.
Hier, guck.
Leute, Curl hat kein Cash
Ich hab keine Ahnung, warum das jetzt nicht funktioniert
Wisst ihr was, ich schmeiß mal
Ich schmeiß Nampai
Dieses Gedöns
Schmeiß ich mal wieder raus
Okay.
Road checked.
Ist Numpie hier noch drin? Ja, weg damit.
Geh weg.
Oh, perfekt.
Und was muss man jetzt sagen? UV Sync?
Minus Numpie. Perfekt.
Weil an sich funzt.
Guck. UV App Run.
Ne, UV Run App.
Minus S.
1, 2, 3, 4.
Oder ne, 80, 80 muss ich da machen.
Low-Close-Port 8080.
An sich funktioniert das hier.
Ist das richtig?
Es gibt kein Package-Requirement.
Ja.
Hat sie geknurrt.
Mal gucken, ob er das jetzt checkt.
Wenn er kopiert jetzt den Kram rüber
Ich hab keinen Plan
Warum es nicht geht
Aber werden wir gleich sehen
Wenn es jetzt nicht geht
Dann werde ich diesen Punkt mal ignorieren
Okay wie funktioniert das mit
Fast RP
Also ich kenne
Ich kenne vom Lesen
zwei Python-Sachen. Das eine ist Flask
und das andere ist FastAP.
Für was verwendet man was?
Das ist in der Tat nicht
sonderlich kompliziert.
Fast, API, Async, Flask ist nicht Async. Aha.
Was jetzt für Bastelkram wahrscheinlich nicht so viel juckt.
Aber wahrscheinlich will man Async haben. Ja, macht Sinn.
Hat er denn jetzt hier ein Bild? Ist das jetzt das neueste Binary? 17.28 Uhr, ja.
Okay.
Ja.
Jetzt
findest du es. Das war
wegen dem Compile-Fehler, glaube ich.
Jetzt findest du es. Guck hier.
Localhost 1234.
KQ am Start.
Ich glaube,
.NET hat sich da auch ein bisschen was von abgeguckt.
Also das heißt, im Endeffekt,
wir können uns diesen, wenn das mit Fast-API
funktioniert. Da kann ich
jetzt diesen ganzen HTTP-Server
Wir machen das jetzt einfach mal.
Kann ich diesen ganzen
HTTP-Server wegschmeißen
und dann sage ich
hier FastAPI
Erstmal importieren.
From FastAPI
Install Package FastAPI
Jawohl. Gebe ihm.
Okay
Diesen ganzen Krempel
Den spare ich mir jetzt mal
Jetzt sagen wir
Fast RP
Äh
Ah
Okay
Aber woher weiß man denn jetzt auf welchem Port das lauscht?
Fast-API-Port?
Ja, schön und gut.
Du brauchst noch
Uvicorn oder Hipcorn?
What?
Das wird er mir wahrscheinlich gleich sagen, denke ich.
Guck mal.
Okay, dann machen wir mal das Beispiel hier.
Einfach wie im Beispiel.
Das sparen wir uns hier jetzt.
Wir machen so.
Und dann sage ich sowas hier.
Get slash.
Okay.
Und nun sage ich run.
Okay, so funzt das schon mal nett.
Weil der Server nicht läuft.
Achso, jetzt muss man
UV Run Fast RP Def.
Moment, das ist ja
nicht wirklich das, was ich machen will,
oder?
Ich will das Tool an sich starten können.
Ist da irgendwie
ein ordentliches...
Start Fast
AP from Code.
First Steps. First Steps ist immer gut.
Ja, das ist für uns ja nicht.
Ja, das will ich doch nicht.
Ich will das Ding vom Code starten.
Run.
Fast.
AP from Code.
Ja, ja, ich weiß
Deswegen suche ich sowas wie Surf
Halt, das ja
Ah
Okay, deswegen braucht man diesen Server
Okay, verstehe, verstehe
Also sprich
Ich muss dann sowas machen wie
Uvicorn
Run
App?
Okay, gut.
So, gibt's nicht.
Install and import package.
Unicorn ist ein Ruby-Web-Server.
Ist das das Python-Gegenstück davon, oder?
Expected? Okay, whatever.
Redeclared App
Define a Buff without Usage
Ah, App
Okay
So heißt ja schon
Okay, das ist dumm
Meine Anwendung
Dann nenne ich es mal API, okay
Jetzt muss ich hier
Add API wahrscheinlich machen
Okay
So, und das funzt jetzt
Ah
Okay
Das funzt, sehr gut
Und das surft jetzt auch, ja
Curl
Acht, acht
Jawohl, Hello World
Wir wollen bloß hier nicht Hello World returnen
Sondern wir wollen hier returnen
app.content.html-content
Das kommt wieder weg.
Ah, nee, das geht nicht.
Muss so.
Tag!
Da sind wir.
So, und jetzt ist die große Frage,
ob man das jetzt
Compilen so an kann.
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Gucken wir mal.
Bild.
Mal gespannt.
Und Chat, meint ihr, der macht da jetzt eine Self-Contained-Anwendung draus oder das backt irgendwie rum und kackt ab?
Wäre schon nice, wenn das funktioniert.
Weil so ein bisschen API-Zeug...
Ich denke auch, das ist doch alles plain Python-Zeug, ohne C-Module, ohne noch was.
Deswegen denke ich auch, das müsste eigentlich funktionieren.
Ich habe die Fernbedienung von meiner Klimaanlage nicht.
Moment, Rich, der kompiliert jetzt auch noch Rich auf einmal.
Warum das denn?
Ich benutze Rich doch gar nicht.
Wonkes?
Das dauert jetzt drei Stunden, bis das kompiliert ist.
Hilfe!
Das, das, das...
Oh, nee!
Okay, das könnte jetzt echt dauern.
Gibt es eine Alternative?
Ja, einfach nicht. Commercial benutzen.
Okay, Chat, Chat, ich muss noch mal kurz abbrechen.
Ich remove.
UV remove Rich.
Besser.
Was, UV Sync?
Mal mal bilden.
Ach, Fast Arby benutzt Rich unter der Haube.
Okay, das heißt, wir können uns das gar nicht aussuchen, ob wir das verwenden oder nicht.
Dann Pech, dann müssen wir jetzt tatsächlich nochmal 5 Minuten warten, bis der ganze Krempel compiled ist.
Also, Buildtimes sind mit dem ganzen Ding wirklich jenseits von gut und böse, ey.
Die sind unterirdisch, die sind schlimmer als große Rust-Booten.
Naja, okay. Naja, wobei...
Nee, nee, okay, große Rust-Projekte sind vielleicht ähnlich schlimm.
Und große C++-Projekte bilden erst gar nicht.
Es wird schon Rich sein, weil...
Ich habe Rich ja gar nicht benutzt bei mir im Code und eben habe ich es hier drinnen gesehen.
Pydantik, das kenne ich vom Namen her auch.
Pedantik, das ist doch
Irgendwas mit Types
Irgendwas mit statischen Types
Ist das
Für Type Annotations oder irgendwie sowas
Für Types und Validation
Ja, wie gesagt
Ich lese immer
Nebenbei, so wenn es Sporeadded Posts gibt
Und so, ich bin auch in dem
Python-Subreddit und ich lese da öfters was,
aber ich mache halt selten was mit.
Deswegen, ich habe viele Sachen schon mal irgendwo gehört,
das ist so an mir vorbeigeschwebt,
aber noch nie benutzt.
Jetzt müssen wir kurz warten.
Ich trinke noch mal was.
Man merkt immer,
abends droppen die Viewer einfach mal
so um 40, 50,
weil Abendessen-Zeit.
Und es ist Samstagabend.
Das darf man auch nicht vergessen.
Natürlich streame ich gerne für mehr Leute als für weniger Leute.
Aber das ist im Stream oder generell so die Basteldinger.
Das würde ich auch ganz ohne Zuschauer machen.
Weil mich das interessiert.
Deswegen finde ich nice, dass trotzdem so viele Leute da sind.
Weil letztendlich macht es natürlich schon mehr Bock, wenn noch ein paar Leute dabei sind, die mitraten können.
Abendessen beim Streamen. Ja, auch nicht verkehrt.
Zoom Walker 500. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich gucke mal nach. Ich hoffe, ich habe nicht noch mehr vorhin vergessen.
Lass mich das gerade mal checken.
Übrigens, wem der Stream und wem solch Content gefällt, dem kann ich jetzt nur an der Stelle empfehlen.
Ihr könnt ja einfach auch followen.
Muss ja nicht immer ein Sub sein.
Follows sind auch nice.
Grüne Pfeile, die nach oben zeigen, sind beste.
Sebidev,
Dankeschön, den Sub habe ich vorhin, glaube ich, gar nicht gesehen.
Dabi hat auch subscribed.
7LQRS, Leute, ich habe euch
gar nicht gesehen.
Dankeschön für die ganzen Subscriptions.
YouTube-Kanal.
Ich war letzte Woche tatsächlich mit dem Fabian ganz kurz davor, zusammen was aufzunehmen.
Aber der hat dann bei sich was hochgeladen und dann haben wir es sein lassen.
Äh
Mein Chat ist gerade abgekackt
Was ist da los
98%
Wir haben es gleich Leute
Der Moment der Wahrheit naht
Ob das jetzt mit dem Webserver
Funktioniert oder nicht
Jetzt out of memory
Wie viel braucht das eigentlich so
Okay zu spät
Okay, Bild
App, Bin
Port
Kunst
Localhost, 1, 2, 3
Oh, wir hätten den Content-Type angeben müssen
Der denkt, dass das standardmäßig
Jason ist
Ähm, der denkt, dass das, der denkt, dass das Jason ist.
Okay, das ist nicht so schlau.
Aber das macht ja auch Sinn.
Das heißt ja auch Fast API und nicht Fast HTML oder sowas.
Fast API, Surf, HTML. Geht das?
App, Mount, Static, Files
What?
File, Response
Nein
Nein, ich will nicht File, Response
Ich will
File, Response
Ich will Dings, was gibt's denn
Was gibt's denn da sonst noch
Ich will
String Response
Okay, das scheint super kompliziert zu sein
Fast AP String Response
HTML
custom response fast ap
ok streaming response redirect response html response
return html response
Äh.
Stalett?
Okay.
Geiler Name.
Den kann ich nicht aussprechen, aber vielen Dank für den Sub.
Also, wahrscheinlich muss es dann so sein.
Ich will nicht Playtext, ich will HTML-Response haben.
Fast Arpy ist ein Starlet-Rapper.
Was ist denn Starlet?
Ist das nicht die eine aus The Boys?
Ich hab da nur die erste Staffel geguckt.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt funzt.
Oh ne, jetzt kompiliert das wieder 3 Stunden.
Chat, ich bin dumm.
Ich hätte...
Ich hätte mir das Verzeichnis in dem gebildet...
Ach, Starlight, genau.
Ich hätte mir das Verzeichnis in dem gebildet wird,
beziehungsweise den CC-Cache...
Den CC-Cache hätte ich mir...
...mountain sollen.
Irgendwie und wieder rein.
Weil ansonsten brauche ich jetzt ja für jeden Bild
5 Stunden.
Was Massive sagt.
Äh, by the way, das ist Blödsinn, was ich hier mache.
Warum lasse ich das überhaupt bilden?
Ich will das runnen.
Viel besser.
Local Host, 8080.
Bam.
Kunst.
Easy.
Damit, damit ist bewiesen.
Es geht.
Also, wer auch immer vorhin gefragt hat,
ich glaube, der Chillfreak, irgendjemand,
hat gefragt, ob das mit
Unicorn und Fast-RP
geht und sowas. Ja, es geht.
Was schon nice ist. Wir gucken mal,
wie groß die App jetzt ist. Das ist
letzte Amtshandlung für mich heute.
Äh.
Achso, ich kack, Noob.
Fuck.
Ich hab die gelöscht.
Jetzt muss ich die wirklich nochmal neu bilden.
Okay, müssen wir nochmal drei Minuten
warten. Aber ich denke mal, das dürfte
jetzt eine ganze Ecke größer sein.
Was schätzen wir denn?
Wie groß das jetzt ist?
Ich sag mal 23 MB.
Chat, was meint ihr?
Wer am nächsten dran ist, frees up.
Jetzt sind wir in 24.
6-7 natürlich, was sonst.
By the way, wenn ihr denkt, bei 100% ist er fertig, das stimmt nicht.
Da fängt er erst richtig an.
Jetzt fehlt eigentlich nur 420
Dann haben wir alle Zahlen durch
Aber das wäre dann doch echt ein bisschen viel
Tja
Chat, habe ich gesagt, welche Einheit?
Aber sagen wir mal MB
So wie die meisten sich das gedacht haben
Okay
Jetzt erstmal eine Runde Däumchen drehen
Guck mal, wie krass das
Konfilieren meine 8-Kern-Kiste
Auslastet, Alter
FastAPI nutzt viel C im Hintergrund
Ach ja, ist das wirklich so? Ich hab gedacht, das wäre
Irgendeine Plain-Python-Implementierung
Also die meinen mit Fast
Dann, dass es schnell ist
Die meinen mit Fast nicht, dass man es schnell erstellen kann
oder?
Oh, wie Core nutzt
C. Okay, aber es ist nice,
dass du da Compiler stellst. Das kann.
Oh, es ist so nice.
Langsam.
Residenz-Sleeper.
Wusstest du übrigens, dass Curl zu Bash-Pipen mittlerweile nicht mehr Stand der Technik ist?
Nee, wusste ich nicht.
Also, es war schon immer relativ blöd, das auf einem wichtigen System zu machen.
Aber man pipet jetzt direkt AI-Prompts in seinen Agent.
Ja, gut.
Leute, es gibt auch Leute, die irgendwie einen, so einen, wie heißt denn das?
Harness? Ne, so einen Bot, wie OpenClaw oder sowas verwenden
und dem Zugriff auch ihren kompletten Rechner mit allem drum und dran geben.
Also verrückte Leute gibt es halt immer.
Sehr viele große Lips sind nicht nur pure Schlange.
Ja, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Das verstehe ich auch, weil pure Schlange ist
halam, ist fuck. Python ist eines der
langsamsten, also wirklich
richtig im Vergleich zu anderen.
Langsam klingt jetzt einfach nur langsam.
Nein, das ist wirklich eines der langsamsten
Sprachen, die es gibt.
Von allen,
die nennenswert verbreitet sind.
Bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob es schneller als Bash ist.
Aber wahrscheinlich schon.
Aber Python ist wirklich richtig langsam.
Und das kannst du nur kontern, dass viele halt C-Module haben.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Bash das noch so macht
Komplett, oder ob das nicht vorher einmal drüber guckt
Oder so, weiß nicht
So
So, jetzt können wir mal gucken, wie groß das Ganze ist
Also erst nochmal hier Bild
App Beweis. Es läuft noch.
Also jetzt schauen wir mal, wer von euch
da am nächsten dran gewesen ist.
16MB!
Leute, war gestern
unsere App mit Rich nicht schon größer?
16MB ist vollkommen
fein eigentlich.
Wer war hier?
Der Unix-Fan.
Oder? Ja.
Der Unix-Fan war am nächsten dran.
SebiDev, du warst nicht weit weg.
Aber er war ein Byte weg.
Und du bist zwei Byte weg.
Leider.
Eins vorbei.
Nicht, dass ich es jetzt übersehen hätte.
Wo ist er denn hier?
Ich finde ihn gar nicht.
Ah, da ist er.
Jetzt habe ich mir selbst Geld gespendet.
und die andere Hälfte in Bezos gespendet.
Haben die enorme Speedbumps bekommen?
Das weiß ich nicht, ob das sich da nennenswert verändert hat.
Aber ganz ehrlich, wir haben ja hier von einer Sprache geredet,
die teilweise hundertfach langsamer ist als schnelle Sprache.
Also das ist krass.
Selbst wenn das doppelt so schnell geworden ist,
ist es immer noch langsam.
Ich weiß nicht, gibt es das da?
Python Performance Comparison.
Moin Flo.
Guck hier.
Das ist das, was ich meine.
Python ist wirklich mit Abstand eines der langsamsten Sprachen, die es gibt.
Also C++ und ist ganz vorne mit Fortran.
Fucking Fortran, Alter.
C, Go ist nur leicht dahinter.
Rust ist auch nur leicht dahinter.
Java auch nur leicht.
JavaScript, ich sage es immer wieder.
Die Leute, die JavaScript sagen, es wäre lahm.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
JavaScript ist viel, viel schneller, als man denkt.
Und dann geht es halt richtig hoch.
Ja, Python PyPy.
Warum ist...
Chat, das müsst ihr mir jetzt erklären. Das verstehe ich nicht.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Ist PyPy
nicht eine Python-Implementierung
in
Pythons selbst?
Warum ist sie so viel schneller?
Ach, die machen JIT.
Okay, und der Standardinterpreter ist halt aber die Schlamm hier.
Ja, ich habe allerdings nichts Neueres gefunden.
Also, deswegen meine ich ja, selbst wenn das doppelt so schnell ist, ist es immer noch langsam as fuck.
Okay, Chat.
Schön, dass ihr dabei wart. Sehr nicer Stream.
haben wir wieder einiges gelernt.
Wir werden auch demnächst weitermachen.
Das heißt, wenn es euch gefallen hat, könnt ihr mir jetzt
einen Follow dalassen. Dann seid ihr das nächste Mal
wieder direkt mit am Start.
Wir werden da noch ein bisschen weiter basteln,
weil so wirklich meine
Python-CLI-Skills
habe ich da jetzt nicht
wirklich
gut
verbessern können, aber
ja, da kann man auf jeden Fall
ein bisschen was lernen.
Gut. Dann gehe ich jetzt was futtern.
Und noch ein bisschen
Stream gucken oder so.
Wir sehen uns bis morgen früh.
Macht's gut.
Morgen früh wieder aufwachen, streamen.
Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.